let me take you through the headlines so
far if you are just joining us nearly
200 seats have now been declared and
it's been a bad night let me return that
a terrible night for the Labour Party
they've seen some shock results in the
Northeast in particular so far a huge
drop in their share of the vote the
Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn has arrived
in Islington in North London for the
results of his count and questions are
being asked directly by a Labour MP a
former Labour MPs over the future of his
leadership a Jeremy Corbyn should
announce that his leap he's resigning as
leader at the Labor Party from his count
today is absolutely he should have gone
and you know he should have gone many
many many months ago and the
Conservatives have made big gains
putting them on course to win something
like an 86 seat majority predicted in
the the exit poll you made just a
Verdean Duncan Smith their former leader
retaining his seat despite a big attempt
to get him out by Labour I'm pleased
therefore incredibly grateful to them
that they have returned me once more to
represent this constituency and I'm also
incredibly pleased that it looks like
that I shall be doing so starting from
Monday in a conservative majority
government thank you very much indeed
shoot sister well no no time to catch
our breath let's talk to the former
Conservative MP former attorney general
now the independent candidates for what
was his seat as a conservative but
beckons filled Dominic grief joins me
now did did you see any of this coming
yes I think it was fairly obvious from
the very start of this election campaign
that it was being commenced on the
footing that was undesirable for those
who had an argument to make in respect
of moderation and the reason for that
was because the Labour Party was being
led by a person who is not moderate in
his views and therefore is a bogeyman to
a very large number of the electorate
and that from my point of view standing
as an independent was always going to be
a very considerable challenge because
the fear of Jeremy Corbyn means that
people feel that they're between the
devil and the deep blue sea and
therefore they're more inclined to the
deep blue sea even though they don't
trust mr. Johnson that's always going to
be the case you did it's featured very
prominently in the course of the
campaign okay I mean you talk about
challenges and and your personal
feelings I mean personally do you think
it's a challenge in in beckons feel that
you haven't been able to overcome yes
I'm sure that's the case it's pretty
tall order anyway to take on a 25,000
conservative majority that I've built up
over 22 years and the area is deeply
conservative why did you bother their
political inclinations because it was a
debate that is well worth having and has
to be had and indeed this election is
not going to resolve it if anything it
shows our even higher level of
polarization and bear in mind that the
polarization is now it seems to me to
begin becoming even very acute both in
the context of Northern Ireland's
relationship with the rest of the United
Kingdom and also that of Scotland so as
I'm a unionist
that's a matter of great concern to me
and something that was a very good
reason for standing that was the reason
for doing it otherwise I could just have
walked away yeah and I never
John Bercow wants a word dominate you
and I have known each other for over
thirty years and we've been colleagues
together in the House of Commons for
over 20 years let me just say this to
you if you have been under not going to
continue are lamont for beckons field I
think the House of Commons will be
poorer I think the country will lose out
because you have been an outstanding
public servant independent minded
principled articulate and unfailingly
courteous to everyone with whom you're
dealing at all times you are really an
exemplar of how politics and public
service all be conducted okay well that
from John burka but you're not gonna be
an MP Dominic griever yeah you know what
what does this tell us then about you
and other independents from all parties
it seems we're back to the to the big
two if you leave you're gonna get thrown
out that may be the case although it
doesn't mean as in the future
independence may not prosper in certain
circumstances it certainly highlights
the difficulty that independents have
and I've always accepted that in taking
this on I had I had a desire to do this
because I thought it was right also had
quite low expectations but it's always
worth going forward and making
democratic debate because the future of
our country depends on it and I am very
worried about our country's future I
think it's a serious risk both in the
quality of life of its citizens and
indeed our future as a United Kingdom
what are your thoughts about the nature
of brexit no doubt that withdrawal
agreement will be passed by the House of
Commons very soon but it's the shape it
then takes after that and you know this
one theory doing the rounds isn't there
with with this size of majority if it
does turn out to be that it pretty much
looks that way might even be a bit low
that exit poll the way things are going
in freeze Boris Johnson up he doesn't
even have to pay any attention to the
ERG
well I don't know about that Oh time
will tell whether mr. Johnson's policy
succeeds and on that note I'm going to
have to leave you okay I've been called
over to the table for the candidates so
I wish you a pleasant evening for the
president thank you very much
great talking to you mr. green we have
to go as well because there's so so much
more to discuss better agree he is very
busy not very but he won't have any
commitments in in the House of Commons
and that serious point a you know just
on this on the squeeze again by the big
- well the biggest squeeze coming from
the conservative party but all these
independents Chuck Ramona they're
failing and many more to come
it's always the way though that yeah but
in of course individual MPs of
incumbency factors but then you cannot
kind of overcome the party machine and
you saw in the city in Westminster seed
that chukka emunah didn't win that had
one of them stood down labor all the Lib
Dan's had they done an official pact or
a non-aggression pact one of them would
have won but the vote was split but
there's another thing that's happening
tonight as well which which John touched
upon which are there are many a great
Parliament mat parliamentarian whether
you agreed with their politics or not
that are now leaving the Commons as a
big churn for X it really did bring John
well I mean I'm particularly from the
Conservative Party we saw those that
were thrown out lost the the whip while
they were mp's some of them standing
again some of them didn't decide do you
think that's just overall just a
terrible loss of parliamentary talent
that is my honest view I've always
admired people who I think are dedicated
conscientious articulate principled
intelligent public services whatever
their view if their dedicated public
servants whatever their view is if it if
we lose them to lose dominate grieve to
say goodbye because of retirement all of
a net win to lose just the greening and
the roads gone he's chosen to stand down
I think is great buddy by the way I just
saw just looking at Joe Swenson they're
arriving for her count the Lib Dem
leaders some of the exit polls saying
she might be in some trouble continue
John Dermot man I just mentioned
somebody who is perhaps
known throughout the nation but I think
I saw in the distance that how East have
been retained by the local party and if
that's so that is Carl Turner now Carl
Turner who is by background a barrister
and the person that's got to say there's
some flash photography John Ferrier is
like live pictures there but no continue
back to Carlton no I just wanted to
mention Carlton are a barrister by
background a very agreeable fellow by
disposition is nevertheless the noisiest
member of the House of Commons and I
have advertised that fact to audiences
around the world Carl goes from naught
to 60 in about five seconds and it's his
usual refrain to yell at the government
shocking it's a disgrace and then to
point at the minister and to say how
does behave okay smiles on Jess
Winston's face there now listen it's
just over five hours since we brought
you the results of the broadcaster's
exit poll the astonishing results on the
bottom of your screen there and plenty
of those results are now in our team of
election analysts have been tracking
those results and is ready to update the
prediction contained in the exit poll
[Music]
and we at Sky News and out forecasting
the Conservatives will win between 358
and 368 seats and labor between 192 and
202 that would mean a conservative
majority off between depending on which
end of the forecast you go with it
between 66 and 86 so a range of 10 seats
in it for both those parties let me take
you through them again sky are
forecasting clearly a conservative win a
very large majority the Conservatives
and Boris Johnson will win between 358
and 368 seats at Labour one nine two to
202 and Sky's election analyst professor
Michael Thrasher is with me now tell me
how you've worked this all out Michael
well we're looking at actual results and
we've been waiting to get enough results
from every region because we're using a
regional swing model and it's very it's
really quite close to what the exit poll
is saying although we we may be saying
that actually the majority may be
slightly lower than the exit poll had
forecast so if you like the mid-range
forecast that we're looking at currently
would be a majority of 76 well I mean
you're amazed by the way this is panning
out this is the you know the fourth
election when the Conservatives gonna be
the following a majority or the largest
party you've you ever seen anything like
this no this is an exceptionally unusual
election and for me now that I think the
critical figure psychologically and of
course electrically is whether labour
will pass you know the important mark of
200 seats and on the upper end of our
projection a forecast of for labour is
202 seats but they could be as low as
192 but even on 202 even on the high end
of that that still worse than Michael
foot in 1983 and still yes and you'd
have to go back to 1935 for such a low
result as that so
but we are getting closer and closer to
being able to sort of pinpoint where the
parties may actually finish up but this
is actually after just 200 results are
in so less than a third we're seeing it
happen because Sid John and I were
conjuring just just on the numbers from
the exit polling you more less staying
on this where the seats are being won
and lost because it seems the
Conservatives are losing some seats
particularly in Scotland and indeed
parts of London and the south east but
boy they're compensating for it
elsewhere yes but they're also I mean
for example labour held onto the stay
with us might go better go to Richmond
Watson Foreign Secretary again targeted
by these tactical voters here we go
Pizza Warren also known as Baron badger
326 three to six Harding Monica
Bernadette Ethel Rhetta
twenty-eight thousand three hundred and
eighty nine to eight three eight nine
[Applause]
Keynes Kylie three hundred and forty
seven three four seven rob Dominic
renny31 thousand one has held on a big
effort there to get rid of him the
Liberal Democrats running him very close
on twenty eight thousand the Labour but
dropping down to two thousand eight
hundred Dominic Rob back there another
important seat Richmond Park declaring
Zac Goldsmith trying to hold on for the
Conservatives only Sarah Jane Liberal
Democrats $30 and 559 Shaw Caroline
Teresa independent two hundred there we
go you can see for yourselves the Lib
Dems have taken it Sarah only ejecting
Zac Goldsmith from Richard Minh parties
rather yo-yo there in a by-election
himself which he lost over the issue of
expansion of Heathrow Airport he got
back in well he's out again now and
first Lib Dem gain of the evening let's
go to Anna botting talking about the big
beasts now Anna botting is in Uxbridge
in West London we're doing about there
the prime minister's seat Anna what's
going on there we're actually talking
about the shadow Chancellor's seat John
McDonnell Hayes and Harlington the
result just come in John MacDonald won
it but while he was making his
acceptance speech talking about people
waking up in poverty food banks and
climate change people started shouting
first of all terrorists and then liar
and then a fight broke out take a look
at these pictures from the count
it is quite clear that there are fears
also now for our democracy
and the rise of the extreme right but I
say now that we will organize and we
will ensure this type of democracy will
reign our democratic wishes of our
people will be respected and this sort
of extreme right-wing violence will not
be tolerated within our society thank
you very much
so the response there of John McDonald
as he walks away but it shows really the
febrile atmosphere that has we've been
brought to during this campaign and now
he of course blaming the far-right we
have to say do not know who it was who
was scuffling there in the background
but even during the postal voting we saw
arguments here as well so clearly
tensions running high
kate mccain you're here certainly a very
extraordinary scenes here at account
with somebody so seniors shadow
chancellor yeah you can really feel the
tension in the room and you could see
there from that footage just how kind of
violent really that fight was was a
proper punch thrown somebody was punched
in the head john mcdonald before that
happened was making a speech which
sounded very much to me a bit like a
leadership pitch we've heard Labour MPs
across the country say Reed Smith very
pointedly before that Jeremy Corbyn
should have announced his leaving
Uxbridge to go to the result in
Islington North Jeremy Corbyn see
Islington nods thank you I Lindsay
Robertson being the acting returning
officer at the election of a member of
parliament for the Islington North
constituency held on Thursday the 12th
of December 2019 to hereby give notice
but the number of votes recorded for
each candidate at the said election is
as follows Nicholas Charles Ellsworth
the elves known as Nick the incredible
Flying Brick the official the official
monster raving loony party 236
[Applause]
James Clark conservative and unionist
party 5,000 483 Jeremy Bernard Corbin
Labour Party thirty four thousand six
hundred and three
[Applause]
yosef hyeme david brexit party 742
Caroline Russell Green Party 4326
[Applause]
Nicholas Richard way chling known as
Nick way chling Liberal Democrats eight
thousand four hundred and fifteen the
total number of ballots rejected is as
follows want of an official mark zero
voting for more candidates than a voter
is entitled thirty-seven writing or mark
by which a voter could be identified to
be so Jeremy Corbyn there are holding on
to his their constituency in Islington
North with over thirty four who
surprised of course that the Labour
leader is winning here in Islington
estate he's held all the way since 1983
but while it's not in a pressure here
he's clearly under pressure in the rest
of the country with a very disappointing
night for labour losing many seats
outside London weather
[Applause]
disappointing night for the Labour
leader and now we'll do polls including
from his own colleagues for him to
resign saying a huge thank you to the
returning officer and all the staff and
the police that have ensured a fair and
democratic election has taken place
today and also to congratulate and thank
my fellow candidates for their
participation in this election and also
a very heartfelt thanks to the people of
Islington Norse for electing me again
for the tenth time to represent hissing
to North in Parliament I'm very very
proud to do so and I've learnt so much
from the people are visiting to North
and it's my pride and my pleasure to
continue to be their representative in
Parliament I also want to thank Ruth
Hayes our agent for this election and
all of the wonderful friends comrades
and supporters in hissing to North Labor
Party for the huge effort they put in in
this election campaign and they put in
all the time to carry a message of hope
and justice all over our constituency
and through me I hope to a wider world
the pressure on those surrounding
politicians is often very very high
indeed the media intrusion on people's
lives is very high indeed and the
attacks that take place against family
and loved ones of politicians continue
and they're disgraceful and frankly they
are disgusting
I want to take this opportunity to thank
my family my close friends and those
that have been close by and been very
supportive during this and every other
election campaign I want to thank my
three sons for the huge support they
give me and thank my wife Lara Alvarez
for all that she puts up with because of
the way in which the media
a v' towards me towards her and indeed
towards my party during this election
campaign and this
this is obviously a very disappointing
night for the Labour Party with the
result that we've got but I want to say
this in the election campaign we put
forward a manifesto of hope a manifesto
of unity and a manifesto that would help
to right the wrongs and the in justices
and inequalities that exist in this
country for those who need housing those
who need an effective health service
that will deliver for them and those
children that need a school that is
properly funded and they're not being
told by oversized classes and a
manifesto that gave hope in dealing with
the environmental crisis the world faces
by investing for the future through a
green Industrial Revolution all of those
policies were extremely popular during
the election campaign and remain
policies that have huge popular support
all across this country
however brexit has so polarized and
divided debaters in this country it has
overridden so much of a normal political
debate and I recognize that has
contributed to the results that the
Labour Party has received this evening
all across this country the issues of
social justice and the issues of needs
of people will not go away just because
brexit is dealt with in the way in which
Boris Johnson presumably plans to deal
with it at the moment all those issues
will come back center stage in the
debate and the fundamental labour
message about justice and equality
within our society is going to be one
that is there for all time because it's
the very core of what my party believes
in and what I will always advocate on
behalf of my constituency and on behalf
of my party I want to also make it clear
that I will not lead the party in any
future general
election campaign I will discuss with
our party to ensure there is a process
now of reflection on this result and on
the policies that the party will take
going forward and I will lead the party
during that period to ensure that
discussion takes place and we move on
into the future because I'm very going
to go from the Labour leader currently
how much longer asking her to the former
and most successful leader of the Labour
Party evers former seat tony blair's of
course Edgefield
is it a back order to turn at the said
election is as follows Paul David
Richard brexit party 3518 furnace John
Charles the Green Party 994 how old Paul
the Conservative Party candidate
nineteen thousand six hundred and nine
choice Michael Anthony independent 394
Welsh Don Elizabeth Liberal Democrats
1955 and Wilson Phillip Labour Party 15
thousand and ninety six I said what a
symbolic result
Tony Blair's old seek just as we were
listening to Jeremy Corbyn talk it's
turn blue the Conservatives have gained
this from labour Phil Wilson ejected as
the end people how old will now take
over in the new House of Commons a
majority a healthy majority 4513 this
year 1935 keeps coming up well that seat
has been labour since then as well and
this is looking like turning out to be
the worst performance by labour since
that year 1935 and Wow we've been
speaking of a while we've been listening
to Jeremy Corbyn you saw the primary
arrived at his count we will also bring
you the results from Boris Johnson in
Uxbridge in his speech when that happens
but meanwhile the inroads that Boris
Johnson's party is making into labour
territory continuing barrow-in-furness
has fallen and the Conservatives have
gained back a high peak a loss for them
in 2017 it goes on and on death it
really does but I mean Jeremy Corbyn is
just effectively announced that he
intends to resign as party leader he
just confirmed at his count I will not
fight another general election as leader
of the Labour Party but he didn't seem
to be in a resigning immediately he said
that he would stay on for a period of
reflection so maybe he intends to stay
on and try and just get his people into
place for any leadership contest so not
an immediate resignation but I mean
Jeremy Corbyn is just there announced
his intention to resign now I'm waiting
for the time frame I mean John Becker oh
man if it's I mean in this exit poll in
our projection it is going all Boris
Johnson's way now you got in we
mentioned Tony Blair that so I mention
you got in in that in that landslide
went I suppose against the trend a bit
pretty safe seating bugging them but you
you got in in 97 and you saw you know a
smashed party how long does it take to
recover from a drubbing like that oh it
can take a very long time
it's always very tough if you suffer a
heavy defeat in terms of size of
majority to get back into government in
one go it doesn't mean it's impossible
it was a very tall order so far as the
timescale for the election of a new
leader of a political party is concerned
I do think there's anything particularly
odd about what Jeremy Corbyn has just
said I mean if you think for example of
the Conservative Party in 2005 after a
notable and quite heavy loss Michael
Howard announced that he would step down
but that he would oversee a process
leading to the election of a successor
and he finally stood down several months
later so anything is anything
particularly quirky or irregular about
that it seems to me to be a perfect
alderney thing to do but what Jeremy was
signaling was that he didn't intend to
try to lead his party into a subsequent
election that seems to be crystal clear
yeah a lot of cell searching perhaps
going to go on pretty soon in that party
let's set concentrate on that what is
gonna remain clearly on this projection
the party of government where they're
big majority there he's got you can see
that mane of hair on the right hand side
of your screen with his back to us the
Prime Minister Boris Johnson we're
expecting his result very soon we're
gonna hear that all here the result
under here his speech afterwards as you
may know Anna botting is there over to
you Anna lots of hair ruffling I have to
say but inwardly that man must be
absolutely delighted it does appear that
we are looking at the next Prime
Minister for Great Britain and Northern
Ireland Boris Johnson it's his dream job
he was already Prime Minister but now he
has his own mandate Kate McCann is here
you've been following him for the last
five weeks there was nervousness was
there not yeah there was and I think a
lot of people including these
politicians have been burnt by previous
polls and of course what happened in
2017 but the Conservative Party in this
general election to focus their
resources on those Midland areas and the
north which Boris Johnson needed to win
needed to turn blue and it looks like he
has and they played an offensive game
didn't they really going after those
leave voting seats in the Labour
heartlands so was it brexit was it
Jeremy Corbyn was it both or was it this
man did he make the difference because
Teresa made tried to do the same in 2017
what difference has it made then that
Boris Johnson is the leader of the
Conservative Party right now
I think certainly anecdotally speaking
to people in some of those seats on
those visits it has made a difference
because lots of voters particularly
those who voted labour for a significant
amount of time have said that they are
voting for Boris Boris Johnson not the
Conservatives not the Tory Party so yes
it's made a difference it's also about
timing we're much further on in the
brexit process and I know Kate Lacan
that you heard people out and about
campaigning with Ross Johnson suggesting
they were not voting for Jeremy Corbyn
because he was anti-semitic and too
close to terrorists the shout we heard
tonight at John McDonald's constituency
so Sophie what reaction has there been
where you are then to the news that
Jeremy Corbyn will not stand or not
continue to stand for much longer as
Labour leader well I think that there
was a bit of shock freely in the room
Jeremy Corbyn is now just left at the
counter you can probably hear the chairs
been packed up behind me but a really
significant piece of news unfolding in
the last 30 minutes or so because as
those labour seats fell like dominoes
Jeremy Corbyn stood on the stage behind
me and announced that he will not be
leading the Labour Party into the next
general election he said a period of
reflection is needed there was clearly
my understanding is some soul-searching
going on about the regional disparities
in the labour losses that we've seen her
this evening and what needs to be done
about them he says he will stay on as
lay believer while that period of
reflection goes on he will then cleared
away for a challenger and I have to say
they've been 2 counts going on here
tonight
isn't a North Jeremy Corbyn feet but
also Islington South in Finsbury which
is the scene of emily Thorne bury the
shadow foreign secretary she gave a
speech moments before Jeremy Corbyn
which sound an awful lot like a
leadership pitch at saying that we're
not beaten the fight is just starting
against the duplicity as gutless
breakfast Prime Minister that is Boris
Johnson my sense here is very much that
with Jeremy Corbyn effectively
announcing that he is going to be
departing the political stage sues the
race to succeed it is going to be
kicking off pretty quickly
very interesting Sophie thank you very
much indeed well the the noise you can
hear in the background now is actually
that Boris Johnson's dog is at the count
Dillon who we saw obviously he took him
voting with him earlier today but
certainly for the prime minister the
person I say the Prime Minister we don't
know yet do we it's not to be confirmed
a Dermot back to you for the moment okay
Anna thank you very much indeed lots of
developments they just keep coming in
dawn Valley has fallen to the
Conservative Party Caroline Flint going
there and you may remember at the start
of the campaign that a lot of flooding
in the area and it was thought that sir
the reaction by the government might
might have had a lasting effect on the
election who knows about that anyway
Caroline Flint ofcourse supporting the
withdrawal agreement bill against the
Labour whip and many votes wasn't enough
to save her though in that leave leaning
seats there you go look how far the
Labour vote fell 17.8% nearly 18 percent
the Conservatives didn't actually go up
very much but the brexit party have come
in there Nigel Faraj deploying his party
against those labour seats and taking
13.7 percent of the vote is is that what
made all the difference Lib Dems up a
smidge as were the Greens also hearing
are just in terms of seats have been
watching closely five northeast now this
was the most marginal seat in the
country what's something a little bit to
cheer for the Liberal Democrats - that's
right the majority are off - therefore
Stephen Geffen's well he's outs and the
Lib Dems are are back in is there a
little bit to cheer for the Liberal
Democrats taking that see there you go
let's have a look at it so um by the
standards of that seat of thumping
majority for Wendy chamber in 1316 four
figures she'll be happy without Stephen
Geffen's 18,000 447 I mean and the other
side of that coin is is that it's
clearly not very be going entirely the
SNPs way they're predicted to get
something over 50 seats tonight up from
35 so it is going to be
not therein fried northeast well look I
mean in the big scheme of things 35
seats in 2017 they were hoping to get in
the mid forties the projection puts them
back in the 50s I mean you know Scotland
is Goan
SNP again and what was interesting was
there was a sort of expectation that the
Conservatives great Grimsby bet we all
want to see this knowing absolutely
[Applause]
Christopher Paul the brexit party 2,370
[Applause]
Emerson Leighton the Green Party 514 80
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with Nigel - Jillian's independent 156
[Applause]
say - that one there was an intake of
breath here John burger Melanie on out
10,000 891 and look at that change the
Conservatives there 18,000 150 in great
Grimsby it just does keep going on and
on excuse the pun labour since 1945 yes
a pro brexit avalanche has knocked out
liliane she stood up for herself she
argued the case for a less anti brexit
position she signaled a willingness to
go along with some sort of the drawn
agreement but I think that what the
evidence very clearly shows is that when
the tide is running strongly in one
direction and the very appropriate
remedy and the tides running against
your party simply standing up and saying
oh but I didn't go along with this
however well-intentioned he is unlikely
to avail you 16.7% I mean someone's in
great grief he wasn't here Monday
handling the fish in the fish markets I
mean I have to say like Melanie on
there's lots of Labour MPs in leave
seats that probably wish they'd
batteries may still now yeah indeed your
wood sorry just lets this is point out
there you could just see Jeremy Corbyn
at the back of that throng leaving his
County in North London there when John
Burke I was saying reading between tho
case letting us know that after a period
of reflection he's gone yes well I mean
that's how I entertain you in gently
dignified statement that he's made but
just to go back to those losses for
labour Caroline Flint share of the boat
was very sharp and got about as well
very shortly down and on Bonnie indeed
okay well listen let's do some analysis
Sam coats is crunching through all these
numbers and we've been looking Sam at
this issue of the brexit party standing
only in these labor formerly labor
health seats what effect are they and
others having thanks Dermot well it's
been fascinating to look in this
election at both the brexit Party and
the Liberal Democrats and it looks as if
the Conservatives were quite right to be
worried about the impact of the in over
two Oxbridge prime minister's seat let's
listen in
[Music]
I lied white being the acting returning
officer for the election of a member of
parliament for the Oxbridge and South
Ruislip constituency do hereby give
notice that the number of votes recorded
for each candidate is as follows
Harvey Jonathan David commonly known as
count bin faced independent 69 who's
David
Stephen commonly known as Lord
Buckethead the official monster raving
loony party 125 Burke Norma independent
22 Courtney Jeffrey Dennis UK
Independence Party 283 Humphreys Jo Ann
alone Liberal Democrats to stop brexit
3026 johnson alexander boris TEFL
commonly known as Boris Johnson the
Conservative Party candidate 25,000
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
25350 one Kia mark Alyn Green Party 1090
[Music]
Milani Ali Riza Labour Party 18140 one
right we don't need to go any further
then now we can clearly see the result
there they didn't lay a glove on him in
reality our ally Milani they're a huge
effort by the Labour Party to decapitate
Boris Johnson there there we get him out
a huge attempt to mobilize some tactical
votes there but you see the Liberal
Democrat for 3,000 of them they're still
stayed with Joanne Humphreys but the
Prime Minister returned as they didn't
really lay a glove on him there twenty
five thousand three hundred fifty one
for mr. Johnson we should hear from him
very shortly indeed let's just take you
through some other numbers we'll keep
our eyes on the left-hand screen and
turn that into some analysis for you or
where we hear thank you all very much
listen I don't want to I don't want to
tempt fate because clearly lots of
results are still coming in and we're
still only dealing with projections but
at this stage it does look as though
this one nation Conservative government
has been given a powerful new mandate to
get grexit done and not just you get
brexit done but to unite this country
and to take it forward and to focus on
the priorities of the British people and
above all on the NHS and yes we will
recruit 50,000 more nurses and 6,000
more jeebies and we will build 40 new
hospitals and I am proud to say that one
of the across the country and one of
those hospitals will be right here in
Uxbridge and South riesling and I am
grateful I am grateful once again to the
people of Oxbridge incise Ruislip for
returning me to serve you
an absolute privilege to do this job and
to work for you and I thank once again
the the police the council everybody
who's worked so hard all night to count
for us the returning officers I thank my
fellow candidates in all their glory
lord Buckethead and others Elmo and
others forgive me if I if I don't if I
don't identify them all but I Bubb all I
want to thank I want to thank the people
of this country for turning out to vote
in a December election that we didn't
want to call but which I think has
turned out to be a historic election
that gives us now in this new government
the chance to respect the democratic
will of the British people to change
this country for the better and to
unleash the potential of the entire
people of this country and that is what
we will now do and if we are lucky
enough to be returned as the polls as
the exit polls seem to suggest then that
work will begin tomorrow thank you all
very much
or rather I should say not tomorrow
today thank you all very much thank you
[Applause]
well the Prime Minister there returned
in Uxbridge and as you heard they're
rather cheekily perhaps they're staying
with those campaign pledges that was so
questioned in particular about the fifty
thousand nurses he said they'd be new
ones fifty thousand new nurses and and
the 40 hospitals well that's by the by
because there was a big attempt as we
were saying before we heard their
numbers there too to get rid of Boris
Johnson and they didn't really get very
close and as they must say as the Prime
Minister was speaking the news just
keeps getting better and better and
there so the defeated Labour candidate
Ali in Milani yeah just just before Anna
botting is they want to hear from her
but Joe Swinton East Dunbartonshire the
Lib Dem leader 55
David model McLeod UK Independence Party
you kept 208 Liam McKechnie Scottish
family party 197 kalmyk Nally Scottish
Labour Party 4849 Carolyn's gamja
Scottish Green Party 916 Joe Swanson
Scottish Liberal Democrats nineteen
thousand five hundred and twenty Swinton
we're talking about a so-called b-cup
identity me Colin who've Boris Johnson
well in terms of leaders you've gone
that's the second one no I drugs on to
Westminster leaders the DUP has gone on
the SMP as you can see there have taken
these Dunbartonshire Joe Swinson will no
longer be an MP well so many questions
being asked even during the campaign
about the nature of the Lib Dem campaign
well we'll talk about that an awful lot
more later but there we are
Joe Swinson is out of Parliament another
gain for the SNP well we knew from the
exit poll it was going to be a good
night for the SNP they had to win the
seats somewhere and they've won one of
them gained one of them from East
Dunbartonshire the SNP triumphant there
let's listen to the winning candidate
and then one presumes from a rather
upset looking there yes a rather upset
looking John Swinton he's the winner and
to all those work in the count tonight
and two polling stations all across
Eastern Barton sure to say thank you so
much for your patience in your
commitment and this is an absolute
privilege in thank you the good people
of east in Barton sure for putting your
trust in me
as your new MP our work tirelessly to
represent you all that sends a clear
message to Boris Johnson that the people
of Eastern Barton reject austerity we
reject poverty and we reject all of the
damage that the Tories and the Liberal
Democrats have imposed on the people of
Scotland
and a personal note from me what I see
it's a Boris Johnson his hands off
are they NHS but emphatically this is a
clear message that the people of Eastern
Barton sure want to choose our own
future not the future of Tory's the
Saudis have been imposing on us this
could not be a stronger mandate for us
to do so so Boris Johnson your lesson
loads and your lesson clear Scotland
stood enough of your policies being
imposed on us we deserve better
a nice Tim Barton sure has said that by
electing me as their MP I have so many
people to thank him from a partner Sean
who's been there for every single high
in every single law empty my parents
who've always taught me to believe in
myself from my brothers my boss I'm a
close friend Rona McKay MSP Mike sandy
family and friends
Malaysia agent Gordon Amma campaign
manager Danis and to every single
activist who chops one door or ten doors
for me who delivered one leaflet at a
thousand leaflets for our campaign thank
you all because of our hard work and
dedication and commitments this campaign
we're one step closer to our
independence due to your hard work
to any young women out there watching
this you get two women here with varied
after an ideological views and myself
and Joe Swanson but what you can take
and what we show you together is that
young women can smash boundaries they
can smash barriers so don't ever let
anyone tell you that you can or that
you're not good enough
believe in your sales theory that means
you'll have and know that there's no
limit to what you can achieve and
finally just to finish off there's one
person that I really wish was here
tonight to share this with me
um I was the very cause for injured in
this campaign him who believed that I
could be the MP Feliz in Barton sure
long before I thought I could him so
join this one's for you thank you
everyone thank you
well I'd like to thank the returning
officer and all of the staff that have
been involved in this election campaign
in emergency services and all of my
fellow candidates and congratulate Amy
wholeheartedly it is an amazing job I'm
sure you will love doing it and I wish
you well and what you said about young
women and smashing boundaries I
wholeheartedly agree I would also like
to thank my agents Liberal Democrat
campaigners and activists who have made
this campaign special with the
additional challenge of doing it as
leader of the Liberal Democrats too I
particularly would like to thank my mom
my sister Nicola my husband Duncan and
our two darling boys Andrew and Gabriel
and I would like to thank the people of
Eastern Barton sure for putting your
faith in me for 12 and a half years to
represent this wonderful place I have
enjoyed serving our communities I've
enjoyed having the opportunity to make a
difference whether it's here on local
issues whether it's supporting people
working on the national minimum wage by
introducing penalties for rogue
employers whether it's women in our
economy by introducing gender pay gap
reporting tonight we have seen that it
is likely that Boris Johnson is on
course to get a majority and it is
clearly a good night for the SNP some
will be celebrating the wave of
nationalism that is sweeping on both
sides of the border and I do
congratulate all those who are newly
elected these are very significant
results for the future of our country
and I will be making further remarks
later today but let me say now for
millions of people in our country these
results will bring dread and dismay and
people are looking for hope
I still believe that we as a country can
be warm and generous inclusive and open
and that by working together with our
nearest neighbors we can achieve so much
more Liberal Democrats will continue to
stand up for these values that guide our
liberal movement openness fairness
inclusivity we will stand up for hope
Josh Winston there the leader of the
Liberal Democrats no longer an MP though
just narrowly lost her seat there in
eastern but ensured to the SNP majority
of 149 or Amy Callen of the Scottish
National Party so not too good night for
the Liberal Democrats just got an awful
lot worse personally for Jo Swinson
she's not returning to Parliament the
many many questions then about her
leadership but a very big win then very
big scalp for the Scottish National
Party and predicted to do well well
they're already doing very well in in
Scotland they're obviously up 9 seats so
far they've taken four from the Labour
Party they're just hearing therefore Jos
wins and the Lib Dems have taken st.
Albans but I want to go now to the
leader of the Scottish National Party
Nicola Sturgeon and this was her
reaction to that results in eastern
Barton sure her candidate getting out
[Applause]
[Applause]
well she joins me now live Nicola
Sturgeon I take it you were sad pleased
about that result didn't look very
magnanimous no did at your reaction yeah
I'm delighted for Amy Callahan she's one
of the bright young stars of this
election and I predict great things
ahead for her but can I see no signs in
that understandably excited reaction
Cuba's additions to Jos Swenson I
understand more than most the pressures
and the challenges of leadership and to
lose her seat tonight when she's late
our party through this campaign will be
a better blue folder so on a personal
level I really feel for okay we'll do it
but of course I can't help but be
delighted by the performance of my party
yeah exactly we'll take that a
celebration for the party and as I said
there's the prediction and there's the
reality what you're up nine seats so far
already plenty to declare if you get
above 50 which it looks like and some
what does that mean then for your
campaign for another independence
referendum well if we win the election
and it looks as if we don't course to
win the election and win it well you
know the exit pull me slightly over
state where we end up but we're going to
win this election and we put forward a
very clear proposition and people at
Scotland will have made very clear that
they didn't want Boris Johnson as Prime
Minister that the dawn warned breaks it
and they want Scotland's future to be in
Scotland's hands and there is a mandate
now to offer the people of Scotland a
choice over our own future that Mandy
already existed and it has been
reinforced I absolutely readily exempted
not everybody who 14 SNP yesterday will
support independence necessarily but
there is a clear desire an endorsement
for the notion that Scotland should not
be landed with a Boris Johnson
government and ripto of Europe against
her will we should have a choice over
our own future and that mandate has to
be okay and just what you've been
talking to us you may not have noticed
or been told oh here your party's taken
from the Conservatives as well may be
time for another little jig perhaps not
why while you're on there but keep I'll
keep myself a bit calmer okay thank you
but but I mean in a sense it's not that
bad you say well okay you know
Johnson is pretty clearly going to get
back into Downing Street whether with a
big majority brexit in terms of the
formal exit from the European Union is
going to take place but in a way if
Scotland wants to remain doesn't that
then help you in your campaign for an
independence referendum I'm bitterly
disappointed at the result Yukie way
that I think 2d governments are bad for
the UK I know that they're bad for
Scotland and I really don't want the UK
to leave the European Union but I've got
to accept the England appears to have
voted in a particular way they appear to
have voted for a Conservative government
and appear to have voted to endorse the
UK leaving the European Union so Boris
Johnson we have a mandate to take
England out of the European Union he
emphatically does not have a mandate to
take Scotland out of the European Union
and Scotland must have a choice over at
all the future because it can't be any
clearer than it has been made in this
election today that Scotland doesn't
want a five-year Boris Johnson
government and doesn't want to lose our
status as a European nation and what
about choice it's about seeing very
clearly it's not for Boris Johnson to
say it's Scotland's future it's for the
people of Scotland to decide it but so
many questions flow from that I might
only have time to put one of them choose
we just watching by the way Boris
Johnson's car taking him back into
central London we don't know if he's
going to do Downing Street or to
Conservative Party headquarters to
congratulate the staff there but but
Nicola Sturgeon that how does it happen
given we're looking at Boris Johnson's
car anyway not the man himself but we
know he hasn't he's not changing his
view he's not going to growl at you and
he's not going to grant you another
referendum
I think I'm not I looks as if and we
don't have all the results in Scotland
yet but it looks as if the position that
I put forward of offering people in
Scotland the choice has yet again been
endorsed by the people of Scotland in
this election so that question really
has to be for polished rods and he has
no right to stand in the way of that
choice sees every right supposed
Scottish independence and I think he has
to think carefully I think the Scottish
Conservatives who've suffered
significant defeats
they have to think very carefully this
is about respecting mandates and
respecting choice spoken cannot be kept
in the Westminster system against its
will
it can only be kept in that if it
chooses that and that is the choice that
must be given and I think the tool you
really have to think long and hard about
the position because it is not a
sustainable one in the long term judging
by the chairs behind you you might have
won another one but I do have time for
the second question may I put this to
you and this is on the issue of
rejoining European Union Scotland will
obviously still be part of the UK that
leaves and you know that's a thorny
issue you had cast-iron reassurances if
you get that far if you get independence
that the EU will let you back in and
indeed without joining the euro no
country can be forced into the euro and
and I have no doubt at all that it's not
and chooses to be independent will be
welcomed with open arms in the European
Union of course we will have to go
through the process if we are out of
that but you know the European Union is
an organisation that has existed to
enlarge itself it was always fanciful
and 2014 to say that we wouldn't be
allowed to be in the European Union and
of course back then we were told that
rejecting independence was a way to
protect our European membership so this
scare stories about Scotland not been
allowed into the European Union will
simply not wash again okay I just see
it's because you've taken the cheering
cuz some people taken Glasgow northeast
are another one another labour one down
it is quite astonishing is it over the
course of what five years or so you've
wiped labour out well you know I'm
afraid is responsible for its own
position in Scotland
labour has lost touch with people in
Scotland it's phoned itself floundering
on the issue of independence on the
issue of brexit and it's got some very
hard thinking to do I mean look Scottish
Labour there's no an existential crisis
in Scotland but thankfully is not for me
to worry about in the immediate future
and you know I'll continue to do what I
can as First Minister to make sure
Scotland is not in the position of
having to put up with a Tory government
we don't vote for and a break says that
we don't want okay you've got a question
here coming in to you from John Bercow I
guess for the evening Nicola Sturgeon no
actually wasn't a question from me to
Nicola I just wanted to say that while
acknowledging the enormous triumph of
the SNP in eastern Barton show which
deserves to be acknowledged I did think
that Jo Swenson made an extremely
gracious concession speech on which she
should be congratulated that's a very
difficult situation I think she handed
it to her in Burien conceded that I mean
I obviously I'm delighted for any
candidate there but I think it's very
difficult situation for just winced and
I do personally as a leader of a party
feel for her right now and you know it's
difficult for women in politics perhaps
even more so than the male leaders so
I've got a great deal of sympathy and I
agree that I think the speech to me
there was incredibly gracious
I just lastly on the nature of the
progress you're making there you you're
interpreting it quite clearly as an
endorsement of of another independence
referendum but you've also mentioned of
course the the issue of brexit Scotland
doesn't want to leave isn't partially
your vote about that it's not entirely
an endorsement of independence it was an
emphatic rejection of brexit but you
know given how England has bought it it
looks as if grexit is going to happen
and therefore that makes it all the more
important that Scotland has a choice
about its future because we've
demonstrated yet again we don't want
brexit we don't want to be outside the
European Union I will absolutely readily
concede that not everybody who voted SNP
yesterday will necessarily vote for
independence in a referendum that people
must have that choice and that's the
fundamental issue of principle that was
very much to the fore in this election
and will be to the forward in the days
and weeks to come
Nicola Sturgeon great talking to you
thank you very much indeed the Yankee
leader the triumphant leader of the
Scottish National Party it's gone four
o'clock you're watching the brexit
election on Sky News let me take you
through the headlines
far and our Sky News forecast is
predicting that the Conservatives will
win the 2019 general election by a
majority of between 66 and 86 seats
Boris Johnson as you may have just seen
house retained his seat with the
Conservatives making big gains overall
putting them on course to win a large
majority in line with the forecast
Jeremy Corbyn held on to his seat as
well but has announced he will not lead
labour into the next election clear that
I will not lead the party in any future
general election campaign I will discuss
with our party to ensure there is a
process now of reflection on this result
and on the policies that the party will
take going forward and I will lead the
party during that period to ensure that
discussion takes place and we move on
into the future and Nicola Sturgeon and
the SNP are celebrating and some after
Lib Dem leader Joe Swenson lost her seat
to the Scottish National Party for
millions of people in our country these
results will bring dread and dismay and
people are looking for hope ok we are
just well the Conservatives are just
shorts of this this formal moment so
when they have definitively won this
general election they got a hit
326 seats that's half a number in the
House of Commons plus one there less
than a hundred seats short you can see
of that total and the prediction is that
they'll go way beyond that Beth your
thoughts so far as we just seen seek
after seat in these labour heartlands
for well let's just also pause on Jay
Swenson I mean Joe Swenson has lost her
seat she's gonna have to stand down as a
Liberal Democrat leader and I think
we're gonna get that in the morning she
said she was going to mail it you
further remarks at Davy the deputy he
will be no doubt taking over as a
caretaker leader let's watch to see what
happens is Luciana Berger the former
Labour
P can she win is Finchley and can she
run for the leadership with the Lib Dems
I mean that's something I'm watching and
then the Labour Party I mean Jeremy
Corbyn they're saying I intend to resign
he's going to have a period of
reflection I can't get any sense from
the Labour Party about how long this
period of reflection will be but maybe
as I was saying it's to get their selves
in order in order to try and put a
Corbin candidate in to try and keep the
movement going despite losing two
elections on the back of a Corbin
manifesto to be frank but big shop
tonight Laura pitcock Durham Northwest
she was corbin backer she is someone
from that wing of the party that has
been anointed that was going to be
pushed that was potentially the future
of that movement she might have stood
for the deputy leader she's out she has
lost her seat in Durham Northwest
so there are serious upsets and
movements in the rival parties to the
Conservatives but as you said some of
services I mean Boris Johnson is heading
to being the most successfully much last
early surveys but that HAP's a John
burka
just on that issue of these the
decapitations I'm calling perhaps that's
that's wrong with Joe Swenson gone Nigel
Dodds gone for the DUP jeremy corbyn
saying well he it'll be gone well before
the next election presumably well before
that it's a real drama
well politics is a legalized bloodsport
and it can be very brutal and the
consequences can be both very serious
and very speedy so there are always
surprises is every election I was
particularly struck by what Joe Swenson
had to say and by the manner in which
she said it but the rest I suppose
naturally flows one would expect Jeremy
Corbyn to have made some reference to
the situation and he did and as I said
earlier and I repeat it doesn't seem to
me there was anything particularly odd
or peculiar about the way in which he
responded he said well look I'm not
going to fight another election
as to how we proceed well that will take
a period of time there has to be after
all a process you can't just appoint
someone as leader there will be an
election and I rather a mentioned that
will take place in the months to come
John thing for the time being for that
and of course some dozens more MPs
that's not at the top of their part he's
going and already lost their seats the
majority of them in the Labor Party and
on that note we at Sky News and our
forecasting the Conservatives will win
between three hundred and sixty three
and three hundred and sixty nine seats
prediction conservatives three six three
two three six nine Labour will have
between 193 and 199 below that 200 level
193 194 the Labour Party now that would
mean a conservative majority that the
spread between those predictions of
between 76 and 88 and sky's election
analyst professor Michael Thrasher is
going to be joining us very soon but I
mean it's just that we've been talking
about this is this is the fourth term
for some form of conservative it's
unprecedented Boris Johnson and his team
this is an unbelievable victory for him
as I was saying at the beginning of the
program he was on the back benches a
year ago it wasn't clear that he would
ever get a tilt the leadership the whole
brexit drama in the way it unfolded the
way he positioned himself as the true
Bret satiric got his foot in the door at
number 10 and boy has he converted that
leadership win he's now converted it
into the biggest majority for a
Conservative Party since 1987 just take
that in I mean he has become the most
successful conservative prime minister
since Margaret Thatcher that is an
unbelievable achievement by him and his
team and yes he has done it on that
brexit message and yes it might be that
this is people lending
the vote because they want brexit done
but he has a proper majority and five
years in government to truly transform
this country how he sees fit and that is
a different form of government than we
have had in the past decades so this is
a really big moment for the country and
how we're going to be governed okay
let's talk to Labour's Rebecca Long
Bailey joining us now from Salford and
Rebecca long Bailey there's no good way
of putting this is there really it looks
like it was a disastrous campaign with a
disastrous result for you well it's been
a devastating night so far we've had
great results here in Salford but across
the country we've lost fantastic
colleagues and I think there's going to
have to be a very detailed analysis of
what's happened it's been a very
difficult campaign for everybody
certainly my experience in the north and
across the some of the marginal seats
that I visited was that brexit was a big
issue for voters and it was very
difficult to to try and reinforce our
message of one that tries to bring
together both sides of the leave and
remain divided and certainly it didn't
play out very well tonight yeah well you
say you were hearing that from the
voters you were hearing it from so many
people saying it's it's really difficult
you airing it from candidates I don't
know if you had difficulty in explaining
it on the doorstep people just didn't
really get it did they no and I think
the problem was was that the message you
know was lost in translation some way it
was quite a simple message that we were
going to make sure that we got a
credible deal that we would put to a
final vote and but ultimately many of
our leave voters felt that we were in
extreme romaine party and many of our
romaine voters felt we were in extreme
brexit ear party and never the twain
would meet and our position actually was
to try and build consensus between those
who voted leave and remain but as I say
you know there'll be a very detailed
analysis now of what happened and and
why we couldn't get our message
reinforced on the doorstep but sadly as
a result of that and I'm sure other
factors we've lost some very good
colleagues tonight I'm gonna ask you
about the other factors so just want to
share I'm sure you'd be delighted
Donald Trump the US president has
tweeted imagine that say he looks like a
big win for Boris in the UK look you've
just just seen their Birmingham North
fielder another one as gone they just
just keep dropping it's got to be
something to do with the leader as well
hasn't it
well they'll certainly be an analysis I
haven't spoken to anybody this evening
apart from colleagues in Salford yet and
and it will be an analysis of whether
brexit played an important factor which
elements of our manifesto went down well
on the doorstep and broadly many of the
proposals that we put forward were
received
quite positively but ultimately the
messaging of the campaign and how that
campaign was delivered I think is a key
factor because it's all about the ground
war at the end of the day and in
whichever party fights that ground more
well okay wins the election the
Conservative Party had a simple message
but no policies and and it looks like
they're doing very well tonight they did
indeed well there is going to be a
vacancy we heard that from Jeremy Corbyn
himself he says he's not going to fight
the next election would you like to
fight it as leader for labour well I
think we'll be having discussions within
the party it's certainly not something
that I've been thinking about and we'll
have to convene look at the election why
we lost the election and determine a
process going forward okay Rebecca long
Bailey thank you very much indeed for
your time egg corn ways up here now to
talk us through some of these remarkable
results where the battles are being won
and loss will I say battles more or less
looks like the smoke is clearing the
battle feel it's lost for labour okay so
let's start with can answer quiz
question to the the panel of white
people which do you think is the most
brexit e constituency in the UK
constituency that voted most for brexit
can i offer a view you can be completely
wrong but my hunch would be Boston and
skegness 76 % Boston the scariness if I
said great
I'm up there great Grimsby as well so
71% leave great Grimsby of course
conservatories and let's have a look at
because there's the interesting story
there if we look at the numbers there
we've shown you this before I mean it's
a really striking board this was
supposed to be the the seats that Labour
was defending all of these at the start
of the night were read all of these
seats and it would have taken up to a
full percent swing for other parties to
win these seats just look all of the
different colors there you've got many
Tories you've got the SNP they're up to
6% here up to 8% up to temper so they've
got beyond a 10 percent swing these are
enormous gains you know the idea that
the Tories would be competing here with
would have seen extraordinary the start
of my life anyway great Grimsby where
are we over here
great Grimsby okay so great Grimsby
Humber s3 let's let's just have a look
at this constituency what's going on
beneath the surface when it comes to
great grooms because you know there's an
interesting story here again similar
story in terms of the change in the
share of what we've seen elsewhere so
labour down about 16 points 7 Tories up
by 13% but look over here I mentioned
the brexit leave oh so 71% leave vote in
Grimsby under 45 you know actually quite
a high proportion under 45 bit lit below
the neck but consider that for exit
leave fare okay come back over here
constituencies here great Grimsby okay
what we're going to do is we're gonna
take all of these constituencies and
plot them on chart just showing you the
brexit vote in different declared state
seats so we'll just take this one look
at these they're going to go across all
of these seats and great Grimsby is over
here now these are the areas that voted
the most to leave the EU and that
referendum two years ago three years ago
sorry and then these are the areas that
voted most strongly for remains so we've
plotted them this is every single
constituency that's declared so far
today tonight rather well this morning
and just look at how much blue there is
around here now this is the key
battleground that the Conservatives have
done so well in so far over this
election they've been winning seats off
labour around here and actually if we
could've take a step back and look at
this you know here we have it here we
have what are the new battlegrounds for
this election campaign the Tories really
fighting very well and then labour the
SNP look at how much yellow there is for
the SNP in these areas that voted to
remain these are the remain areas remain
over here leave over here
and just look at that big glut of
constituencies right there you know
we've yet to see at the end of all of
these constituencies being declared more
coming in every moment but already you
can see the geography is changing and
that old geography that we used to I'm
gonna take do the same thing again the
old geography which was all about class
and deprivation we take all those put
those across in terms of deprivation you
know it was labor dominating this area
and now look at how many conservative
seats these are the most deprived seats
in the UK look at how many conservative
seats there are there in these areas
many of them in the Northeast you've got
a lot of SNP there is also winning seats
off labor there and then the Tories
still doing well here but interesting
look labor Lib Dems if fighting in this
area which is the better off parts of
the UK this is a you know the highest
level in terms of you know our
deprivation index the best off places in
the UK when it comes to kind of
qualifications when it comes to housing
quality final final question I'm going
to go back to the to the table off a
final question here
there are three seats here three
conservatives seat I can see doing work
Berko what are you asking okay three
conservative seats there's there's
Henley there's other Hampshire's there's
one other seats which is among the least
deprived in the UK hasn't yet declared
any guesses as to which this seat might
I think what the see might be well I
mean it could be one of several but new
forests west would be an example of that
it's Buckingham Buckingham itself it
would be very I know a little bit about
Buckingham it is not a deprived
constituency although like lots of
places has pockets of disadvantage and I
remember the former MP Tim Collins used
to joke that the last time an unemployed
person was found in the Buckingham
constituency the individual concerned
was expelled and I said Tim that is very
unfair and here you're having a laugh in
a light-hearted sort of way but actually
there are disadvantaged people in back
them as well but overall of course it is
a picture of affluence and there we have
an in it's just interesting that Labour
annelid Dems competing so strongly at
that top end you know including
buckingham but maybe they okay this time
around
join the pop quiz there with our in
business let's catch up on their
developments fast-moving as indeed is
the Prime Minister's motorcade they're
going back in the dark into central
London not entirely sure whether he's
going to Downing Street or could
certainly party headquarters and we're
hearing there is a protest of some form
outside there so keep an eye on that if
he does arrive there other developments
in terms of seats we haven't
concentrated too much on northern island
apart from the fact that the Westminster
leader of the Democratic Union Party
Nigel dogs lost his seat in north
Belfast a result just in the SDLP Social
Democratic and Labour Party er their
leader Colin Eastwood gained foreign
soil from shin Fane one of the most the
most marginal seat in Northern Ireland
the 17,000 majority there is raising the
prospect so many different stories
developing the prospect in Northern
Ireland of more nationalists than
unionists being returned as MPs for the
very first time we've got now keeping an
eye on the prime minister's motorcade
seeing where that ends up and what's
awaiting him at the end of it got the
co-leader though the Green Party
candidate for the Mayor of London Sean
Barry I think joins me now from
Westminster the the Green Party's
performance sean barie you're treading
water at best aren't you
no our vote shows up around the country
looks like we're set to about double our
overall vote share versus 2017 and that
and that reflects the positive campaign
we put forwards the the ideas around
investing in the country remaining in
the EU the positive case we made
consistently for remaining in the EU but
we're making gains in terms of boat
share in leave and remain voting areas
and I think that shows overall the the
positive campaign that we ran in their
artwork of many of our people okay
positive but costly so far you've lost
your deposit in 326 seats
so far we've retained our deposit in
price as many seats as we did in 2017
already just from this decline okay Sean
Barie we'll come back to were going to
Kensington now I believe we're now we're
showing Sean Barie was showing Caroline
we're showing you Caroline Lucas hf4 or
returning officer give notice that the
number of votes for each candidate at
the election of the Member of Parliament
in the Brighton Pavilion constituency
are as follows
Dobbs Bob independent 212 Furness Nigel
UK Independence Party 177 Hogan Emma
Louise Conservative Party candidates ten
thousand one hundred and seventy-six
even poor Adam Labour Party thirteen
thousand two hundred and eleven Lucas
Caroline Green Party 33,000 let's go
take Kensington there is a let them some
Jima there's a Labour MP there Emmett
dent code we are expecting this
declaration there it is let's listen see
June
[Applause]
what a bit of a protest going on there
let's talk a bit more than B until we
get the returning officer speaking there
um well that one of those big gains from
2017 for the Labour Party amid encode
but of course this high-profile Lib Dem
put in there some jima former
conservative left the Conservative Party
across the floor to the Liberal
Democrats and again relying hoping on
some evidence of tactical voting that
let's see if they've split the vote and
giving it back to the Conservatives
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well there as we were discussing
there the Conservatives have got the
numbers for you have gained Kensington
back from Labour evident code gone we
need to see those numbers to see the
effect that the Liberal Democrats had
some jima on that remain votes remain
leaning seat a majority of just one
hundred and fifty as the okay there's
loosely buckin back in in Kensington for
they conservatives a narrow squeak buts
it seems that the Lib Dems and the
Labour Party spit about there and the
Conservatives get it back in they just
want to say they're saying Crewe and
Nantwich has gone this was one of the
ones we thought we would go even if it
wasn't such a good night for Boris
Johnson crew net which is saying okay
again for the Conservative Party but
just let's have a think they're about
Kensington John Burke oh and it seems
they're they just if they wanted to put
a remain alliance together they didn't
get their act together and if we've seen
it in several other seats where they
they had some I hopes those who wanted
at least another referendum and there's
a there's another concern
getting back in yes oh it simply hasn't
worked and the attempt was made but it's
backfired or linear ate not succeeded
and as you say a Conservative member of
parliament has been elected for that
constituency I'm not quite sure because
we've not been given now we need to look
exactly the second and third but it's
also this idea of tactical voting it's
not so much about it online they were
saying this time I think it's the dog
that does it it's the dog that doesn't
bark and the other thing is is the power
of the party system as well because if
you think about the way in which the
tensions within Parliament split people
from their traditional parties in the
last Parliament and you had so many of
the defectors and the disillusioned go
into other parties or standards
independence and none of them have come
through the other side on a super egon
trucker amoun are gone Phillip Lee a
conservative gone Antoinette's Ambika
conservative gone
Dominic Greve gone in beckons field and
now some gamer who was a conservative
who's left who's Luciano I think Luciana
might get that see so that is wonderful
to be engaged and if she does she really
could be in pole position try anything
what were the figures do we know what
the figures I mean that would be a
classic case of a split the remain vote
splitting between labour and that's then
there's the tail of the tape so far and
we'll just concentrate very quickly on
who's gained and lost and the
Conservatives have put on 37 seats so
far and labour have lost nearly 50
listen we were talking about the Greens
was talking to sean barie who's kindly a
stayed on the line to reflect on and I
was saying well treading water was was
my phrase Caroline Lucas we then
interrupted you to to go to that answer
mother can't she'd got back in in
Brighton with an increased majority so
we'll give you that but doesn't look
like you're gonna win any other seats no
our birth target was Bristol West we
doubled our vote there we came in a very
strong second but but the Labour Party
continued to hold that seat we're in a
very strong position there to carry on
gaining councillors and we've got an
election for mayor in that city next
year where we've got an excellent
candidate so that's a very good
springboard for that
but overall across the country we've
seen strong support for many of our
candidates so some big swings to us
we've increased our vote by several
times in some of the unites remain seats
my colleague Jonathan Bartley has got a
very strong second place in Dulwich from
West Norwood these are all places where
we have counselors and we're going to
continue building up green
representatives who when you get elected
is a green but you work hard and you
continue you get an increase vote as
we've seen from Caroline Lucas just now
historic we'll just have a listen to her
I'm totally gonna listen yeah let's have
a listen the darkness I'm very finally
let me thank my amazing husband Richard
my children Theo and Isaac for all of
their love and support all the way along
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay yeah well she's finished then and
delighted and life.you I'm last question
I mean you mentioned this we're we're
calling at the romaine alliance
it was pretty feeble wasn't it compared
to the Conservative Party and the brexit
party that was you in England with some
of the Lib Dems and in Wales with plied
Camry I mean you really had to get some
kind of accommodation with the Labour
Party if you wanted to make any inroads
at all I think I think this election
should be a wake-up call for the Labour
Party that they do need to work with
other parties in order to overcome the
problems we have with the electoral
system it's pretty clear now that the
the two-party system is not serving this
country first-past-the-post is not
delivering votes that reflect the
people's wishes and that and we need to
sort this out and and we should be
getting together and working towards
some kind of electoral reform in the
next parliament but Caroline Lucas will
be there in Parliament she'll be putting
forwards our good ideas making sure that
there's a strong green voice there and
being fantastic as she always is yeah I
mean I just got I've just got to say
that I have an eye so Boris Johnson wins
this large majority through the
first-past-the-post system and is
therefore going to reform the voting
system yeah I can say that and I can't
pretend that Boris Johnson be Prime
Minister is going to be good for the
country
we
needs to see the country renewed he's
not gonna deliver that now he has to
deliver on his election slogan which he
absolutely refused to come on and give
details of and take scrutiny of get
brexit done I don't think in a year's
time we're still going to be mired in a
brexit mass and okay he's got a very
difficult job ahead of him Sean Sean
Barie thank you very much indeed very
quickly John back over to you rightly so
in these circumstances there's no way on
earth the Conservative government is
going to consider reforming the
electoral system from which it very
handsomely benefits that isn't on the
agenda it doesn't mean that Sean doesn't
entitle to make the argument made
against it but that is the reality just
on a positive point I would say though
although it's incredibly difficult for
one person on his or her own to make a
great impact Caroline Lucas I can say
this from the vantage point of the chair
over ten years has been an absentee
outstanding an indefatigable member of
parliament she's her own leader she's
her own Chief Whip and she's ubiquitous
she's there all the time she speaks in
debate after debate after debate she
uses the procedures of the house to
proselytize for a cause and you know she
really is a model MP okay John thank you
very much indeed for that stoke central
has gone it's a gain for the
Conservatives Gareth Snell they're not
returning for the Labour Party the
assault continues interesting
developments shall we we touched on them
a little earlier in Northern Ireland the
headline being that the leader of the
Democratic Unionist Party in Westminster
Nigel Dodds lost his seat many other
developments and there's our senior
Ireland correspondent David Blevins to
tell us about them David yes Dermot if
gadding Briggs are done has worked for
Boris Johnson that certainly hasn't
worked for the DUP they knew they were
in trouble in Belfast
but the big story here is Belfast north
where they're Westminster Leader and
Nigel dogs the man who is Arlene
Foster's deputy leader of the party has
lost his seat to Shin Finn's
John Finnegan with the majority of
around 2,000 votes John Finnegan is the
current Lord Mayor of Belfast he's the
son of the Belfast solicitor Pat
Finnegan murdered by loyalist
paramilitaries back in the 1980s it is a
very
significant moment and let me briefly
try and explain why in losing two seats
the dup are down to it we're still
waiting to hear from from Anna South to
Rome but it looks like on balance Shin
Finn has held on to all seven of its
seats but when you had on the fact that
the SDLP have gained two there are now
nine nationalist MPs and it unionist MPs
nationalist MPs will outnumber unionist
MPs in Northern Ireland for the very
first time in the history of this place
and that certainly will increase the
volume of calls for a border polska
brexit has not only moved us towards a
nother referendum in Scotland but has
moved us into referendum territory here
in Northern Ireland
- so brexit may be done but the UK may
be undone David thank you very much
indeed David Blevins there in Belfast
it's half-past four you're watching the
brexit election on Sky News the
headlines so far and Sky News
forecasters predicting that the
Conservatives will win the 2019 general
election by a majority of something
between 76 and 88 seats Boris Johnson
held on to his seat comfortably with the
Conservatives making big gains overall
[Music]
Jeremy Corbyn has retained his seat but
has announced he will not lead labour
into the next election I will discuss
with our party to ensure there is a
process now of reflection on this result
and on the policies that the party will
take going forward and I will lead the
party during that period to ensure that
discussion takes place and we move on
into the future and Nicola Sturgeon and
the SNP are celebrating this was Nicola
Sturgeon after hearing as she was
hearing that the Lib Dem leader Joe
Swenson lost her seat to the Scottish
National Party
[Music]
for millions of people in our country
these results will bring dread and
dismay and people are looking for hope
[Music]
okay you're watching the brexit election
let's have a look at this winning line
the formal winning nine is 326 seats the
Conservatives are closing in on that
here's ed Conway to talk us through
developments yeah that's right Dermot we
are getting pretty close to that moment
that moment where there may well be a
new government 326 seats all-important
as you said where do these current
results put the Conservatives and the
Labour Party let's have a look they are
getting close the Tories 284 seats and
you can see that line just there that
line they are aiming for 326 remember
the sky forecasters predicted the
Conservatives to get between 363 and 369
seats a majority of up to 86 seats so we
are getting closer and closer you can
see that there now let's just consider
some of the big names the big names who
have been lost from the House of Commons
potentially lost potentially from
portator tonight let's consider first of
all Joseph wince and Lib Dem leader Joe
Swinson in East Dunbartonshire DUP
deputy leader Nigel Dodds and Laura Pitt
coughs some people heal the forest some
people thought that she might well be a
future potential labor leader and
consider as well Caroline Flint let's
have a look at the next route group of
people including Caroline Flint so she
was seen as another high-profile labor
loss at Dominic grieve as well he ran as
an independent in beckons Phil was
always going to be tough for him former
conservative and as well as them Anna
Sabri as well wouldn't went to another
forum Ettore lost tonight and former
Labour MP choco Amana he defected to the
Lib Dems of course famously he will not
be an MP in the new Parliament that's
now official them from early on really
this was shaping up to be a tough night
for labour it's worth looking at another
seat Workington because now we can see
it so you can see it working tonie's
constituency have been pretty much
labour red since 1918 since his creation
but now it is Tory
blue Labour's lost a few of its shadow
cabinet as well including shadow
environments secretary Susan Haven and
Leslie Laird in Scotland on top of Laura
peacock who we mentioned a little bit
earlier but better news for the party in
Hartlepool the exit poll remember
suggesting that the Tories would take
that seats in Hartlepool let's have a
look at that but in the event it was
held by Labour MP Mike Hill and Richard
twice coming in there in a close third
but nonetheless in third place and the
sky for costs has now narrowed the
conservative majority and here you can
see it it's narrowed the conservative
majority from that exit poll it is now
the Skyfall cost at 363 to 369 Donna
incredible okay Edie thank you very much
indeed while ed touched on it there this
issue of the remain alliance what there
was of it there the Lib Dems and their
greens in a lot of seats in England
applied come reuniting they owe they
hoped to have some kind of effect well
they don't seem to be making any impact
no one wears skirts and coach has been
drilling down into those numbers they
haven't had any effect in terms of
benefiting themselves Sam but they've
been doing some damage perhaps as well
to labour so thank you Dermot yes you've
got to remember that we're only having
this election because the Liberal
Democrats teamed up with the SNP to hand
what Boris Johnson wanted and have this
December election yet so far at this
point in the night they have made zero
net gains overall and lost a leader
while also putting on a couple of seats
elsewhere but look at the effect in seat
like Kensington there Sam Dima
was the Liberal Democrat candidate huge
Liberal Democrat resources in that seat
yes it went conservative there were just
a hundred and fifty votes in it between
the conservatives and labour
yet Sam kima got 9,000 plus votes in
that seat suggesting that if he hadn't
been standing perhaps that actually
would have stayed with another party
that supports a second referendum you
could see that same pattern in city of
London the chucker emunah and Watford
really number of seats where if the
Liberal Democrats hadn't been standing
the result could be different and the
second referendum party might have got
into power Sam thank you very much
indeed
I want to join Labour's Hilary Bennie's
at his count in Leeds central and
Hillary been just hearing her just we
country Dudley North another gain for
the sorry Darby North Dudley's already
gone Darby norfair another gain against
your party again for all their
conservatives it just does get worse and
worse it's like some kind of slow-motion
political car crash from your point of
view isn't it
well it's a very very bad night for the
Labour Party it looks as we're heading
for the lowest number of Labour MPs
since 1935 that's more than 80 years ago
and what come on say we have failed to
win the people's trust and confidence we
won't have the opportunity to put our
policies into effect and we need to
reflect on what happened but before we
elect a new leadership to take us into
the battles that lie ahead and Hillary
bear just looking we're just looking
somebody's list all the stoke seats have
now gone conservatives you held two of
them before this general election
newcastle-under-lyme hasn't been
conservative has been labour since 1919
we've been talking about the second
world war
that's just after the first world war
look we know you're no fan of Jeremy
Corbyn there was a point of course when
you tried to get rid of him he's got to
go pretty soon as he well Jeremy I think
in a very dignified speech said he won't
leave the Labour Party into the next
election the precise timing of his
departure is a matter for him I think
it's important that we reflect on what
went wrong how we're going to respond to
this terrible without that we have had
because I think that then informs
decisions about who should take
positions of new leadership for the
party but we will need to get on with it
but in the meantime we have a job as the
opposition to hold Boris Johnson and the
government to account because I think
the promise is going to find things
pretty difficult I'll remove the comma I
mean you will have a job holding them to
account with fewer it scenes than 200
MPs would you tell me what you think
went wrong you at the heart of the
campaign I I think well I think very
simply many voters bricks it was the one
and only thing that mattered and they
voted accordingly secondly any Labour
candidate or canvasser will tell you we
knocked on too many doors where people
said I've always voted labour in my life
but I'm not going to vote labour on this
occasion and they didn't have confidence
in the leadership of the party and
thirdly there were some voters
who said we're not entirely sure that
you can do all of the things that you
have promised and i've evan famously
said once that socialism is the language
of priorities but at the same time there
were a lot of voters who were enthused
by what we had to offer particularly
younger voters so it's not about
throwing all of that away you have to
have credible leadership to win people's
trust and confidence because that's how
you are able to form a government and
then you can get on and try and create a
fairer and a more equal society because
i tell you one thing Dermott what isn't
going to go away is the fundamental
unfairness in the fifth richest country
in the world of over a million people
last year going up to a complete
stranger to say I can't feed my family
and I cannot feed myself will you help
me
now society either says well that's the
price you pay for having this kind of
economy and that seems to be the
conservative approach or you say it
doesn't have to be like that
we can change it for the better and that
thirst that desire for a fairer country
is not going to go away despite the
depth of the defeat that we have
suffered tonight thanks very much indeed
thank you Amanda in Leeds let's just
check in on the Prime Minister's
movements we've got some shots of him
you saw his motorcade arriving into
central London a bit earlier we're told
that he did go to Conservative Party
headquarters no doubt to congratulate
the campaign staff there and their their
well-crafted and successful campaign and
there's a festive downing streets which
we are expecting the Prime Minister to
arrive back at fairly shortly and no
doubt in a very festive mood he referred
in his acceptance speech when he was
elected for the seat of Oxbridge how
jolly it was to have a christmas
election well it certainly worked out of
him let's see get the thoughts of my
panel here John Burke and I want to go
back to what I was discussing there with
Hilary Benn and you know we've been
doing all these parallels with history I
refer to 1919 for newcastle-under-lyme
this is the worst performance since 1935
but isn't the comparison the more recent
comparison in terms of the Labour
Party's future here something like 1992
so
go through these for election defeats in
a row and the Labour Party realizes that
it has to change and change
fundamentally two years later Tony Blair
came along and then three years after
that won a landslide are there any signs
that Labour will address it that way or
will they just think we need more Corbin
or a different Corbin or a better Corbin
I think it's a big challenge to the
Labour Party and I rather agree off the
top of my head that there is some sort
of parallel with 1992 to lose again so
soon after the last victory for the
Conservatives is obviously very very
demoralizing for the Labour Party
particularly when they did better last
time they're not winning they did better
last time than had been expected and
this time they've done very considerably
worse than was expected so some very
very serious soul-searching needs to be
done I do think it's just about a
personality I think it is about a
program it's about a mindset it's about
a philosophy the Labour Party can't just
have what it can have but I think it
would be frittering away it's time
foolishly if it would just have a debate
about personalities it's got to be about
you who'll approach in fact seeing
Hilary up on screen causes me to call to
mind his late and great father that
wonderful parliamentarian Tony Benn who
always used to say as probably Dermot
you'll recall in those debates in the
eighties whenever he was challenged
about some other figure in the party
put away your prepared BBC script mr.
Dimbleby it's not about personalities
it's about issues it's about the
policies it's about the priorities of
conference and so on and so forth and I
think now the Labour Party has got to
have a debate about what sort of party
is what its priorities are and what its
philosophy is to best bring in Bethan on
the other side of this because even in
victory you've been touching on it
during the evening as this story this
remarkable performance it seems by the
Conservative Party has developed it the
Conservative Party now has to have a bit
of a rethink given where it's now got an
awful lot of its MPs in places where it
never did before that's absolutely true
but I think what was so interesting
about Boris Johnson's manifesto was how
slim it was how many pictures were in it
and how little text was in it what he
effectively did was call an election and
win an election convincingly on a single
message of get brexit darn and then when
you look into the manifesto the
tax-and-spend was pretty modest there
wasn't that much commitment the social
care policy was part why was he doing
that well I think he was doing it so he
had latitude and so once he came into
number 10 he could begin pulling the
levers dependent on the majority he's
got but I do think that if he has won a
big group of traditionally labor seats
in blue-collar workers
he's got a different voter base that
maybe want different things from a
government and if they've lent him their
vote in this election to get brexit done
he somehow has to reinvent the party do
with them a reason to vote another time
we will continue this conversation I
want to bring in out Conway though
because he's got some of these
historical comparisons for us you've got
in a big red chart there what does it
tell us ed yeah I mean if that I don't
think any labor supporter will much
enjoy seeing you know this is a
comparison of different labor majorities
over the years and we've taken the exit
poll here so 391 we're currently
forecasting a little bit more than that
but still to be below 200 so below 200
is the projection may be getting up to
199 seats you can see in the bottom of
the screen they're kind of getting
closer to that but the number of seats
that would have we have yet to declare
are dwindling but let's just compare
that with previous eras of the Labor
Government's obviously jeremy corbyn's
result last time around 262 considerably
higher you've got the Ed Miliband years
Gordon Brown there that said that was
seen as a poor result I'm clearly it was
over they didn't remain prime minister
and then the Blair is just look at those
Blair years in historical comparison you
can see there's no other period in terms
of the length of time that labor have
actually managed to to get those
majorities that compares with it Michael
first in 1983 so the famous there long
suicide note in history still over 200
209 seats in other words higher than the
projection for Jeremy Corbyn this time
around and that is historically has
tended to tend to be seen as the worst
ever late performance in recent history
and then go back to the kind of years of
Wilson through to Clement Attlee here
obviously the famous 1945 result there
but there is really no other period
okay comparing what you've got in this
time projected for this election there
was no other period like this that has a
result like this as low as this since
all the way back in the 1930s so you
know that's the other big story of the
night after the conservative like key
victory is what happens to the Labour
Party now now that they are back at the
same kind of levels they saw in 1935 I
mean it will be a staggering a
staggering thing for labour to have to
absorb and who knows quite how they
absorb it and where they go from here
but I mean it's a very stark choice
isn't it DOMA thank you very much indeed
i popping really i wonder it is for john
Trickett Labour's john Trickett who
joins me now i don't know well obviously
you can't see what ad Conway was
describing but you know this is one of
the worst labor performances ever since
dinosaurs roamed the earth while
political dinosaurs anyway what are you
feeling about it well hope you doctor
yes and I'm a dinosaur but look at a
Tsaritsa it's devastating for the Labour
Party I think it's damaging for the
country because things which the
government have promised I don't believe
we do delivered in the way that you said
they have you do need an effective
opposition and where it's going to take
us some time to think through the defeat
and how we begin to rebuild an effective
opposition and alternative government
look I think there were people inside
the Labour Party who gave them some of
them senior who gave the impression that
Labour was simply a romaine party but
how could we really have done that when
these people had spoken especially
across the north of England where I am
here in West Yorkshire people clear they
wanted out the European Union but there
were significant players in the labour
party who were giving a different
impression that was a big mistake and
left the impression that we'd left
behind the very people who supported us
for over a hundred years I know I can
eat them clearing up behind you you I
mean you got it you got back but you had
a much reduced majority didn't you even
though you were sending out you were
sending out that message that we hear
you well you're saying it was then
clouded by the overall message well look
I think I think the first thing is and
this was about right there I've not
about that at all but it symbolized for
many people who thought the past labour
had lost touch with the people who stood
by us for all those decades and I was
warning in private and in shadow cabinet
week after week after that to do that to
go down that truck was dangerous for us
because the majority of labour seats are
in the north of England and the vast
majority of them voted to leave now
politics is part about mathematics as
well as hearts and minds and big ideas
and you cannot win the election if you
cannot persuade a sufficient number of
people to vote for you but we walked
they felt as though we'd walked away
from them that was a mistake
I pointed out clearly and we've now paid
a very serious price probably there were
other mistakes as well but I think that
was the key
yeah I mean what's one of the other big
mistakes this fact of credibility
individually a lot of people when polled
did like a lot of offerings from the
Labour Party but the word what is
important here there were lots and lots
and lots some that popped up after the
manifesto and it added up to billions
upon billions of spending and in the end
people just didn't believe any of it
yeah look at our pockets taken one by
one we're extremely popular I think
everybody could see that they went down
very very well but were they cohere ins
did we offer a way to fund all of the
promises which we were making in a way
which was plausible and that political
economy I think was a problem for us I
go back to breaks it but I have no doubt
at all that we'd need to have a review
about exactly how we did this
tax-and-spend store Jorge cricket
rightly to try to put the problem sorry
to cut it off John tricky we're going to
Devon East there's an independent son
here Claire right to set in with a good
chance legend the Green Party Chuck
Simon Jade the Conservative Party
candidate thirty two thousand five
hundred seventy seven Democrats to stop
practices 1771 Wilson Daniel commonly
known as Dan Wilson the Labour Party
candidates 2817 right Claire L
independence twenty five thousand eight
hundred sixty nine closer twice there in
the past but the Conservatives actually
putting on some boats and just seeing at
the bottom of your screen nearly
fourteen seats to formally win this
general election John Burke oh you know
something about devil you know about all
these these constituencies but as I say
Claire right for it for an independent
is run it close twice called locally
she's very well-regarded and so she got
a dramatically bigger boat than
ordinarily an independent forget she's
been there before and she's done well
but not well enough and it is
traditionally a very strong conservative
seat we have pictures of Boris Johnson
the triumphant Prime Minister arriving
back in Downing Street carrying a red
box I think not too triumphant in the
wee small hours of the morning no doubt
going to get a a few hours sleep after
this long long winter campaign which has
resulted in them I'm gonna set winning
this general election formally they
haven't wanted yet as you can see on
your screen there they are exactly 13
seats away from doing that but plenty
more still to count we're just hearing
well by the way you may have you been
with us all night just hearing that
Christine Jardine from the Lib Dems has
held on there in Edinburgh strong
Scottish National Party performance
there Beth I wanted you to come in near
off the off the back of Claire right not
not doing then this is a bit of a bit of
a theme there you've already been
describing it at these these
independents these people that left to
join other parties sometimes fighting
their Elsie sometimes going to other
ones they just don't seem to have made
it no there was a couple of things at
the beginning of the election that we
thought would be big themes one was the
sort of fall party race the sort of
surge of the Liberal Democrats and the
brexit party didn't happen I mean we're
in two-party territory again and of
course the SNP utterly dominant in
Scotland but in England and Wales
two-party politics and then the other
big theme was the defectors how
disruptive would they be in a campaign
but they've failed to make their mark
really but I think that that's a
reflection of how strong party politics
are on the ground when you're just
grinding out an election campaign but it
does mean that there will be more
discipline again in the Commons there
won't be all these independence or
defectors it's very good point winner
John Berger given what you presided over
well I think that's a pity
personally I think it's a very good
thing for politics when there are some
free spirit
highly principled personally very
assertive individuals who say no
whatever the party says this is what I
believe this is what I stand for this is
but we saw the whipping system kind of
break down and you were pleased about
that there where you you helped it
whatever it could yes I mean I think
that is is I say a good thing I think if
you ask the public they always say what
we want is politicians who stand up for
what they believe we don't just want
people who operate is nodding donkeys we
don't want people who simply take
instructions and vote entirely as
they're told about we want people with a
bit of independence a bit of
get-up-and-go a bit of willingness
sometimes to be different you know you
cannot have a parliament exclusively
made up of people like that in a modern
era parliamentary democracy you have to
have parties and you have to have some
discipline but all I'm saying is three
cheers for those who had a bit of
tenacity and spirit and who that's just
one careers on the line we're close to
formally seeing the Conservatives get
across is three to six but what what's
going through your mind then when you've
heard these arguments about you know we
want sovereignty for the great British
Parliament and then some people who
espouse that very strongly then say well
we can't have this parliamentarians
broke in government policy did what was
your view on it well that's what they're
there for
well I don't say that's the only purpose
of a member of parliament by any means
but it is part of the purpose Member of
Parliament to stand up for personal
causes and for principle and it did seem
to me frankly contrary and inconsistent
when people who had championed the cause
of brexit for years under the banner of
take back control then seemed to inveigh
against the idea that Parliament should
have control I suppose it really comes
down to this question of who governs and
the government took the view that only
the government should initiate
legislation and policy my own view from
the chair was that as it was a minority
government as he didn't have a majority
in the House it must be open to other
actors on the stage who weren't part of
the government to put forward their own
proposal and I make absolutely no
apology for that and far
from thinking that the last Parliament
was a bad Parliament to retrograde
Parliament of Parliament to a denounce I
think it was a good Parliament and I
said it went around the country though
the fact was that the public were really
angry with Parliament is actually really
angry because they felt there's another
irony here isn't it I mean who who
blocked two resumes withdrawal borås
must be speaking autobiographically when
he talks about parliamentarians blocking
breakfast he must be speaking
autobiographically because I'm sure he
hasn't got any problem with his
short-term memory and he will know that
in two out of the three votes on the May
withdrawal deal he voted against it he
voted to block it he voted to stop
brexit now apparently it was alright
when he voted to stop it but when
anybody else chose to do so a different
set of rules apply I'd like to explain
and you can argue that it's not up to
labour to pass a conservative version of
brexit which is why in a way many Labour
MPs didn't want to support Mays deal or
Boris Johnson's deal because it wasn't
the sort of brac sale is not they're
alienated bars whether you like it or
not or whether you think it's fair or
not the way that Boris Johnson and his
team framed it as Parliament blocking
brexit was extremely effective oh the
best
I absolutely acknowledge that it has
been a highly effective focused campaign
on the part of Boris Johnson and his
party with real message discipline you
don't normally associate Boris Johnson
with the idea of discipline and
restraint and sticking to a line but he
has done so the only point I would make
is that although Parliament may be
unpopular and it may be subject to
excoriation by very large numbers of
bases around the country I am sticking
to the view that he was a good
Parliament Jeffrey Cox for example the
Attorney General said this Parliament is
a disgrace well he's entitled to that K
and I'm entitled to the view that it was
actually a good Parliament that should
be cherished just keeping an eye on the
can and four seats in a three please how
worried were you about a No Deal Braxton
did you want to stop it I was worried
about
No Deal brexit but very particularly my
answer is this better
the House of Commons wanted to authorize
a No Deal brexit that was entirely
within its gift and perfectly proper
what seemed to me to be constitutionally
and indeed ethically unacceptable was
for there to be a new deal brexit
inadvertently by accident because we
crashed out and because perhaps because
of the prorogation of Parliament
Parliament had no opportunity to stop it
my point was not that it was for me to
stop an OD or brick snow but to enable
our you actively were you actively
thinking you were actively thinking of
new and innovative ways for those back
benches to achieve it to rule out No
Deal I was certainly thinking of as you
put it new and innovative ways to
facilitate members of the House of
Commons to discharge their duties
absolutely I totally accept that that
was part of my thinking and I make no
apology for that I wasn't trying to will
a particular outcome but to facilitate
those in its pursuit but if you call it
facilitating I mean others called it
plotting ah plotting well plotting is a
rather subjective and loaded term not
the sort of term that I when I set up my
light might have seemed alike - well I
sort of the front page of some popular
newspapers oh you mean some downmarket
rag you may say that I can't possibly
comment John do you mean some organ of
well-known bigotry I think you do yeah I
mean no such thing I think it's um puja
deist newspaper scribbling away a mainly
and constituting tomorrow's
fish-and-chip paper no the
responsibility of members of parliament
is to do what they believe to be right
the fact that they might be subject to
denunciation and in a sense journalistic
flagellation is really neither hill or
that i always took the view that I
should try from the chair to do what I
believe to be right the fact that
somebody was sounding off in the
background and saying how awful it was
and what a disgrace I was and so on say
well didn't lose me a wink of sleep I
couldn't give a TG freedom I mean
there's water off a duck's back wasn't
it
I mean most of the more bigoted organs I
gave up reading some very considerable
number of years ago you're quite right
you're absolutely thought you know me
too well Devon took absolutely no notice
of the sort of bilious bluster of some
of those newspapers and one of these
days one of these days perhaps in my
soon-to-be published book I will tell
you what okay my shyness available in
all good book shops at conservatives
need this is a formal moment approaching
one seat to win to get that that formal
moment when they get 326 seats and
therefore cannot be beaten irrespective
of whatever results come in there
they're on three to five they've been
ticking up us we've been talking and
listening to a marvelous set well in the
end monologue of rock from Tom burka
that we are waiting for the next seat
let's let's build up to that it's going
to come in soon I'm sure
the Conservatives holding Bournemouth
East three to five and holding Worthing
West that is it Worthing West is the
Constituent
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that's it
confirmation of the result the
Conservatives have formally won this
general election taking their 326 seats
meaning they cannot be beaten whatever
happens now I think taking their 327th
as well seeing her Dagenham and rain I'm
John Kronus big beast the Labour Party
they're going conservatives gaining that
the s there it goes up to 327 the
Conservatives and Boris Johnson have won
the general election of the winter of
2019 well a formal moment Beth I mean
you as we were counting that down there
that intake of breath on John Curtis for
John Rogers in Dagenham I had heard that
that was quite tight on the ground but
I'd also heard that Labour were hopeful
of holding it one of very big interests
- John Becker Buckingham is declaring
[ __ ] lumps on the stage
and once I have declared the result each
of them will be invited to say a few
words if they wish starting with a
successfully elected individual and so
to the formal announcement of the
results for the election of the Member
of Parliament for the bokkeum
constituency held on 12th of December
2019 i Andrew small being the deputy
acting returning officer that the
aforementioned election do hereby give
notice that the number of votes recorded
for each of the candidates is as follows
bell Andrew Ronald Macmillan brexit
party 1286 Doral Steven James the both
Liberal Democrat candidate sixteen
thousand six hundred and twenty four
Morgan John David commonly known as
David Morgan Labour Party candidate
seven thousand six hundred and
thirty-eight Smith Gregory David
commonly know in his Greg Smith the
Conservative Party candidate thirty
seven thousand
Thompson Ned Stephens independent 681
good elo Antonio Daniel very clear
victory as expected for Greg Smith the
Conservative candidate ins Buckingham
taking over from official none other
than John Barker your reaction to that
then John
well many congratulations to Greg Smith
I don't know him well but I do know him
I miss him several times in the past
he's a very very dedicated conservative
campaigner he's long aspired to enter
parliament and now he's done so with a
very handsome victory indeed it doesn't
come as a surprise to me it is a very
very deeply ingrained conservative seat
there hasn't been a direct party contest
of that kind since 2005 as a general
election by virtue of the fact that I've
served a speaker that I want to wish
Greg Smith every possible success in
representing the constituency okay also
hearing that heart Southwest David go
that's gone conservative David Gore was
standing there as an independently
ejected of course from the Conservative
Party and you were making this point
earlier John Burke a David Gore gone
from Parliament gone a cabinet rank
minister of course not to very long ago
in the Conservatives gone altogether as
he a loss I think he's a loss he's a
very accomplished guy he's very measured
Bain intelligent reasonable he
represents a moderate Tory tradition
which the party can't possibly afford to
loose and I think it's a great shame
that he's left the House of Commons just
hearing just a little tip John just
hearing from Paul so that if Dennis
Skinner would have been the father of
the house has lost voiceover the
Conservatives in there he's the oldest
MP to lose the seed of the age of 87 and
this is the victor would just tell it
have a look at that
Beth we were reacting to that because
it's Dennis Skinner yes right on the
receipt on the results already he's not
there due to ill health we we understand
but on the results it was always gonna
happen it was it was I that I was not
surprised that done it Dennis Bob also
but but I should just tell you as well
that Luciana bird you did not win in
Finchley so that's a lot of David Gordon
that's another David Cook but I mean if
we just think about what's going on here
in terms of as I said last night ahead
of the polling day Boris Johnson
consolidated a vote leave base going
into this election he went in with 58%
of vote leaders prepared to vote
conservative he came out the other end
with 70 percent and as I said last night
if he could turn out that vote and hold
that vote and get that vote to back him
that group of vote leaf voters he would
get the mandate to deliver brexit and he
has done that with bells on hasn't he
and that all these seats have fallen in
vote leave areas it was the strategy
perfectly executed in this election and
it had an opportunity I mean beyond
getting Breck's had done whatever form
that takes is it an opportunity John
Burke o4a
one nation a different one nation
conservative party though to reassert
itself very much depends on the leader
because in the Conservative Party an
enormous amount hangs upon what is
directed from the top I'm not saying
that there are no democratic
decision-making procedures at all but
they're nothing like as deep-rooted as
they are in a number of other political
parties so really it's Boris Johnson's
call it's up to him to shape and
configure the conservative party the
future in his own image
we've just sorry I've just got a fourth
on the Tories I've just got a correct
one of the results we gave you a
Dagenham and rain has been held i held
by the lake i think we we can run i mean
it's amazing it's in john chorus it's
amazing i was shocked by but it's
amazing given the amount of data we're
processing in the course of one evening
that there's just that - i'm
but just just coming in on what John was
just saying as well there were some of
those anti-node dealers in the
Conservative Party some which got
expelled some which got the whip taker
given back to them and they believed
that Boris Johnson although he had put
himself in full brexit ear armor that if
he did win a majority he would pivot to
who they believe Boris Johnson really is
which is a worn nation conservative and
what has been interested in as we go up
and down the country is although there
was no mention of one nation
conservatism in his manifesto he talks
about it a lot and he and he talked
about it didn't he in his acceptance
speech so maybe there will be a
different John Young USA you were saying
it forward what do you think he knows
well he was politically he'll have to
decide I mean I've always felt that
Boris Johnson doesn't carry a very large
quantity of baggage I don't think that
he has a very large number of dogmatic
convictions I think he does have a very
very strong and enduring conviction that
he Boris Johnson should become and
remain Prime Minister of the United
Kingdom and that's where I draw the
parallel with Disraeli that was very
much Disraeli as approach to politics it
was about getting power and once you've
got power you then it wasn't that I mean
let's draw a more recent parallel in his
big rival for many years of course the
former Prime Minister David Cameron it
was said that he didn't carry an awful
lot of ideological baggage hold the
thought but that's also true the two
statements are not mutually exclusive
badly and spend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
being held by the Labour Party you may
remember that sir it was the seat of the
murdered Labour MP Joe Cox a trace of
Rabbinate took over in that seat you
know holding on there with twenty two
thousand five hundred ninety four a
majority of 3525 and I wonder if we'll
be hearing from Tracy babban in a moment
or two and just at the bottom of your
screen the Tories continued to go well
past that 326 mark were there the formal
point at which they have won the
election three three seven so far Tracy
Brabant
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for labor in battling spend but as you
can see they're pretty much in tune with
what's been happening to labor in lots
of seats they've lost down 12.8% in
terms of share but still how long
they're reduced majority of 3525 also at
the bottom you were screen well some
better news for labor but it's bad news
not for the Conservatives for the
Liberal Democrats labor holding on in
sheffield hallam the seat that labor
took remember that was the seed of or
melindam leader Nick Clegg seems to be a
story of our times that them leaders
losing their seat Joseph 2015 the
wipeout yeah yeah Nick Clegg
gone in Sheffield alum and late lost in
that 2017 and labor have held on Joe
Swensons lost her seat as well want to
talk though okay so something going the
right way for labor but it's not enough
they are be there are as john was
pointing out to me and that's why they
have hit 200 see they have it or they
might underperform on that size Gordon
about to declare now this very
interesting seat was of course once the
seat of the former leader of the
Scottish National Party Alex Salmond
once spectacularly by the Conservatives
that's Evelyn's o'clock Scottish
conservative on unist
23,000 and
[Applause]
however Sony Herbert Scottish Labour
Party 3052 James Bradley oats Scottish
Liberal Democrats 5000 and 913 Richard
Gordon Thomson Scottish National Party
SNP 23,000 885 are so many narrow
margins particularly in a lot of these
Scottish seats three-way and four-way
margins and many of them but the SNP
have taken it back 819 that said the
Conservatives holding on there in
Aberdeen Western Bank and [ __ ]
inhabiting sure but that one it's so
strong the Scottish National Party when
Alex Salmond was rejected it was a high
swing in any seat in the UK away from
the SNP to the Conservatives well
they've taken it back and well rather
expected on that exit poll which is
predicting a very good night for Nicola
Sturgeon and the SNP gained Gordon there
gained it back there from the
Conservatives quick look at their share
in the vote the SNP 42.7% up 6.9 their
Conservatives up a bit as well labour
vote again so depressed it's not as much
as it has been in many seats in England
bets and we'll stay with the Labour
performance because we've got to get
this in so many questions now so many
crab out the leadership journey who've
been addressed it but said he would go
before the next election well that's
probably not gonna be for another five
years well Jeremy Corbyn said he
wouldn't fight of the election but he's
thence talked about a period of
reflection and I think that they would
probably go away and lick their wounds
and reflect and and try and come up with
a plan but now I think a big theme of
the next Parliament will be the civil
war now in labour as to who takes over
and which direction the party goes in an
interestingly when you interviewed
Richard Bergen earlier the shadow
justice ministry was obviously a big
Corbin backer one of the main
protagonists and champions sorry of the
Corbin regime he said we need to fight
back not triangulate we will analyze the
result can you translate that then for
what he's basically saying the project
will continue he's basically saying we
need to continue fighting on the Corbin
project we're not going to move to a
Blair area where we begin to triangulate
ie try and appeal to lots of different
types of voters through our policies and
I think that that's something to watch
for who takes control of the party do
they put it back to a more center ground
position it was the most radical
manifesto it was double the amounts of
public spending that had been in seen in
2017 it was almost like Corbin was
trying to make the manifesto so radical
that it was such distance to travel to
get to a different type of a Labour
Party and just in terms of the runners
of riders who would I have my eyes on I
think we need to look at kiss star mer I
think you've got Emily Thornbury there's
just Philips Evette Cooper will she make
another run for it listen Andy in Wigan
I mean it might be that they decide that
they need a leader who isn't a
london-based
MP okay well we've also been John Berger
just quickly on that and I just went
back a long Bayley of call belly then I
mean I very much identify with what Beth
I said I think there will be a very
strong body of opinion in the labour
party that is absolutely determined this
time around to get a woman but there
seem a certain irony about the fact that
other than for purposes of acting
leadership for relatively short periods
the live body has never been led by a
woman now there are lots of good female
calendars there are good male candidates
but I've just got this sense that there
will be a very strong appetite for a
female condom okay watch this space on
that we're also watching the space we've
been talking about it the effect on the
Union V United King
you may have heard me talking earlier to
the leader of the Scottish National
Party Nicola Sturgeon saying that the
performance of her party was well a
clear message she was saying to Boris
Johnson and to Westminster that there
should be a second independence
referendum in Scotland and in Northern
Ireland there also voted to remain
inside the European Union we are looking
at the situation where there will be for
the first time now more nationalist MPs
elected than unionist ones thoughts to
conjure with and going to be analyzed
now by our deputy political editor Sam
Coates thank you very much indeed Dermot
yes if you look at Scotland to start
with the turnout in Scotland is actually
up in the rest of the country it's down
but in Scotland they turned out about
two percent more and the SNP are the big
winners their share of the vote has got
up to 45% uncannily that's the same
amount that the independent cause got in
2014 and they have SNP have won 13 seats
tonight the last of which Gordon was
retaken from the Tories you heard just
in the last 20 minutes or so that is
bound to put questions about whether or
not that might be could be another
independence referendum over the course
of this Parliament but then you cross
the Irish Sea and you look at Northern
Ireland there again the picture is being
redrawn it looks as if at the moat it
stands at the moment with one seat left
to declare it looks as if the SDLP and
chin Fane the two nationalist parties
have eight seats and the DUP also have
eight seats with the DUP actually taking
a smaller share of the vote 32 percent
or so than the nationalist parties which
are combined on about 35% there has been
lots of talk of the impact of Northern
Ireland in its place in the Union
particularly given the structure of
Boris Johnson's brexit deal I suspect
that the results tonight will put
further pressure and generate further
questions on that in the days to come
okay Sam yes plenty of talking points
there we are hearing a result is
imminent in Barry North now this was
as seats that labor took from the
Conservatives at the last election the
Conservatives wanted back a non-current
former would have a pretty good chance
of doing so we'll have a look at that as
and when it declares but John burka on
that issue of the Union we heard Nicola
Sturgeon saying right and and can you
clear this up for us because I keep
putting it to SNP representatives
including the leader well how do you do
it okay so you're saying this is a clear
message to Westminster but if
Westminster won't legislate we will deal
with that in a moment
Barry North is declaring okay Charlie
green party 802 daily James berry the
Conservative Party Canada's 20 1660
[Applause]
555 Lloyd Johnson Gareth daily Greenlee
well done okay they've taken it back
pretty much on trend there the
Conservatives counts as a game very
narrow though very narrow indeed James
Daly there with 20 1660 and James forth
for lay but just behind there look at
that majority just over a hundred 105
the brexit party and the Lib Dems both
losing their deposits in Barry North I
wonder if I can get back to John Burke
on that issue
Sam Coates was touching on there the
Union in particular Scott and where
Nicola Sturgeon now says they have this
lag clarion call for another
independence referendum how how does it
how does it happen if Boris Johnson will
not legislate for well it remains to be
seen it's a juxtaposition of political
advocacy by the Scottish National Party
on the one hand against legislative
power the power of initiative on the
other the position as I understand it is
very straightforward in constitutional
and legal terms the power of initiative
lies with the UK government it is for
the UK government to decide whether such
a plebiscite whether such a referendum
whether such a public poll can take
place now I suppose if the government
refuses which I confidently expect Boris
Johnson's government will refuse to
allow such a referendum there's nothing
to stop Scotland going ahead with a
public vote of its own and if we get a
territory or indicative it wouldn't have
any binding effect so it seems to me
that ultimately it comes down to a
matter of politics possibly of
negotiation but certainly of politics
and if the UK government which has won
the election by a thumping majority
simply says we will not do this it will
not at any rate for a very appreciable
period happen that said if for a very
very long time for many many years there
is a push from Scotland you know there
may be a sense that politically such a
request has to be acceded to at some
stage but I do think he's going to
happen anytime soon I'm bound to say
okay I listen we're waiting for a result
Jewsbury labor see polish sheriff there
are under attack from the Conservatives
yet again we'll we'll bring that to you
guys and when it happens but ed Conway
scan to tell us the story of the night
so far and how the Conservatives have
won this general election that's what
let's have a look here of course the
main objection for every political party
is to get over the winning line 326
seats and to get into 10 Downing Street
let's have a look at what happens with
this election look at the conservative
line there it is over the winning line
the Conservatives have passed that
landmark and now they are in government
comfortably in government there and you
can see labor they're on 200 seats so
above the 200 marks some people thought
they might not make it that far
will they get more than they got in 1983
a lot of people still trying to work
that out but let's have a look at how
those numbers translate into our results
map our representation of the UK there
you can see the scoreboard on the left
let's fly past that and have a look at
the new political geography of this
country and how does that look all the
way from the more yellow in Scotland's
through to the rest of England where you
can see a lot of blue some labour red
still but a lot more blue than there was
at the start of this evening and we are
getting now to the final stages where
most of those constituencies have been
declared you can see Wales actually
really eating into in Wales the Tories
really eating into traditional labour
territory they're so similar some blue
dots there in Wales and then we saw also
didn't we I mean look up at Scotland
look at that yellow a sea of yellow
perhaps not as much as we saw at the
peak of SNP power a few years ago but
nonetheless a lot more really clear it's
a clearer picture there isn't in
Scotland but let's consider as well some
of the big names who tonight and this
morning we have seen potentially is at
the end of their political career is
certainly the end of their time as an MP
so starting with Joe Swinson Lib Dem
leader in eastern Barton sure she's not
the only big name to lose their seat
tonight also DUP deputy leader Nigel
Dodds in Belfast
North lost his seat there to Shin fain
and Dennis Skinner who would have become
father of the house
he's lost his seat in bowls over he had
stood there Turner he'd stood there for
almost 50 years so it's a really kind of
stunning reversal of fortune we've seen
tonight and who knows maybe there's a
few more twists and turns yet to come
Eadie thanks very much indeed let's go
to Plymouth Plymouth more view to be
precise Johnny Mercer yes Jeff Berger
chime said of course every time you
mentioned a constituency he knows
precisely where we're going out Johnny
Mercer good to talk to you got John
Burke oh here of course who knows your
constituency and all the others inside
out as you know your reflections on the
evening you've crossed the winning line
and going well past it yeah look I think
it's been a successful evening for the
Conservative Party I think the country
really clearly wants to move on get back
sit down I'm moving on to all these
other things it wasn't really a shock if
you spent time out and the doors if you
read the media and spend a lot of time
on Twitter obviously tonight it's a bit
bit of a shock but for the rest of us I
think it was always coming I think the
Labour Party had been peddling load of
nonsense for quite a long time and
they've and they've been punished for it
but you know we need to get on now and
meet the challenges that piano expect us
to what the key walk with the majority
Conservative government that's what I'm
looking forward to what are they what
are the key challenges what do you want
to see taken on head-on immediately
after that withdrawal agreement is
passed brexit is done okay there's a lot
of negotiating to do next time yeah for
me things like public services 30% of my
jobs down here public service public
sector just to Mercer I'm so sorry to
interrupt you when we're going to come
back to you but Winchester is declaring
a Steve brine there who actually did
lose the width or a bit trying to get
back in Winchester let's listen George
Labour Party 2000 723
wine Steve the Conservative Party
candidate 28,000 430 Ferguson Paula
wengie Liberal Democrats 27,000
445
well one of the big Lib Dem targets
there in Winchester but Steve brine
getting back in 28,000 434 him down
slightly on his last performance but not
a good enough performance by the Liberal
Democrats again he was one of these
remain alarm seats there the Green Party
me not standing there well listen let's
say hear more from Johnny Mercer who was
kind enough to hang on there and you
wrote your reflections on holding on to
Winchester Steve Bryan you're you're
calling they're back in black glad to
see him because I say did lose the whip
for a bit yeah look Steve's a good guy
and he's a good one nation modern
compassionate conservative like myself
and I'm pleased that he's come back but
we've got a job of work to do to get on
with the country now and to fix a lot of
the challenges that were talked about in
this election and we're very much
looking forward to it yeah one nation
conservator mean do you see the party
still being bad or has it moved to the
right no I think that's very clearly
been answered by the British people
doing this during the selection
elections are won by parties that are to
try and go for the center ground that
try and go for the one nation agenda you
know fulfilling a referendum result is
not extreme it's actually honoring the
result of the something the British
people voted for so let's get that done
and then move on to all the progressive
modern compassionate conservative stuff
that I know Boris believes in and people
like me or in politics for but how do
you reach that connection with the
public who we all know and it was part
of the conservative campaign how
disaffected they've got with all the
politicians now in a lot of those seats
conservative MPs are replacing Labour
MPs some of whom were self-avowed
socialist s-- how does the Conservative
Party take that on board look I think I
think what you're getting at is fair I
think the a lot of people who put their
faith in us now you know who voted for
house perhaps for the first time that's
a that's a challenge that's a real
opportunity to go and redefine who votes
for the Conservatives in 2019 2020 and
beyond and for people like me who who
think we're on a journey to reach out to
more more voters I think that's pretty
citing I think you know Boris's clearly
got this agenda he's always had this
agenda this is why people like me
supported him brexit has sort of clogged
up the machine but you know once that is
done we can move on to some really
exciting stuff we've gotta invest in the
NHS and schools and all those good
things that you know the British public
wants to see and would it serve them if
by the end of 2020 in Boris Johnson has
pledged that there will be no extension
to the transition period if the trade
deal is not done with the European Union
would it be serving these these new
conservative electors if there were in
effect are No Deal brexit
I think everyone's kind of fed up with
the constant watersports poorest is
pretty clear he's gonna get a trade deal
by the end of next year let's let him
get on with it let's get it done and
meanwhile get on with all these other
things we talks about in the election
that people like me Gordon's problem in
things sorry they're cheering behind you
I wonder if you can still hear me but
you know the thing is is that it isn't
done it isn't done with the withdrawal
agreement there's an awful lot more to
do that the heavy lifting is still to be
done ok Johnny Mercer there thank you
very much any juice breeze declaring
there as I say Paula Sheriff trying to
hold on to a pretty slim majority there
for the Labour Party she can't she go
against the trend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
as I said there Paula sheriff defending
a pretty slim majority certainly by the
standards of this evening of ver 3321
that's been overturned again it goes in
the conservative column it goes under a
conservative gain there's the result
mark Eastwood elected now comfortable
majority
1561 Paulus sheriff will not be sitting
in the next House of Commons it's just
gone half past five and you are watching
the brexit election right here on Sky
News then we take you through the
headlines so far so many of them the
Conservative Party has won the 2019
general election and secured a majority
in the House of Commons the prime
minister who retained his seat says it's
given a powerful mandate to get brexit
done Jeremy Corbyn says he will not need
labor into the next election after big
losses for the Labour Party and some
very big names from all the parties have
lost their seats over the course of the
evening including the leader of the
Liberal Democrats Joe Swinson Dominic
grieve and Labour's Caroline Flint
amongst many others but it has been a
successful night as well for the SNP and
its leader Nicola Sturgeon who was
celebrating there after the Lib Dem
Leader Joe Swinson lost her seat to the
Scottish National Party
[Music]
okay brexit election conservatives have
won John bokor talking to to Johnny
Mercer there and it is I mean it's a
recurring theme now it's going to be
discussed course the celebrations but
it's what do we do now really we do
braixen they've termed it rather
narrowly get the withdrawal agreement
passed but then you've got a big
majority some big opportunities and
maybe some big problems too well there
are gonna be lots of big problems
because governing is an extremely taxing
and challenging business and there are
all sorts of problems some of which are
intractable I think the difficulty
really with the conservative manifesto
was that it was thin almost to being
threadbare there was a number of very
very small possibly valid but very small
ideas in it but it was obviously
designed to be a safety-first approach
and indeed to be a focused manifesto
focused overriding ly and overwhelmingly
almost to the exclusion of all else on
the delivery of brexit now that had the
advantage that's all the resource all
the intellectual resource all the
campaigning resource was focused on that
one subject but it did mean that there
was a huge void there was a blank page
and it seems to me that in manifesto
terms there is dare I said a third way
to use Blair right terminology you can
have ridiculously loaded manifestos that
have got far too many things in them
given that most people don't read them
anyway or you can have a virtually blank
canvas and I change to me that the Tory
manifesto was a virtually blank canvas
now the opportunity of that is that
Boris Johnson can fill in the pages and
it's up to him and others to do so and
if we're going to get a flavor of what
what we're asking for asking for
something better it be we're talking
then pretty soon about to recast cabinet
we had gone on it Ron it seems an age
ago how long to his seat quite easily in
the end in Asia and Walton didn't seem
sure if he's gonna stay as foreign
secretary we here's Santa Javed will say
but that personnel will tell us a lot
won't it yeah look it was it was
interested in the campaign there was
only
one cabinet minister that Boris Johnson
publicly said I'm keeping them in the
job and that was Sajid Javid the
Chancellor
so Sajid Javid is nailed on but everyone
else he wouldn't comment on and yes he
will get to pick his cabinet now I have
to say that given he only selected this
cabinet in July he's been he's only been
Prime Minister for just over a hundred
days I wouldn't expect a gigantic
reshuffle at this point in time but it
was - I mean it was to send out a
message get brexit done pretty but tell
Dominic Robb in there on that on the
hard side Jacob Riis markquart in
brought into government he doesn't
necessarily have to keep them there does
he he doesn't have to keep them there
but he's going to get a very different
party it's gonna be a very different
makeup in his parliamentary party now
there's gonna be a lot of new people who
have to learn the ropes and he's not
he's lost a lot of big beasts as well so
maybe he will sort of sit and think
about that I wouldn't expect a big
dramatic reshuffle he doesn't need to be
radical right at this moment he probably
the focus will be for Boris Johnson not
what his cabinet looks like it will be
getting the withdrawal agreement bill
and the Queen's speech through the
Commons before Christmas because he
promised people that he would get brexit
done get the withdrawal agreement passed
by the end of January and he needs to
get a read and through the comments
before Christmas doesn't need you okay
much much much more on that coming up
but let's bring you up to speed it's 538
just turned in the morning and the
Conservatives have won the general
election and Sky News can now project
the size of their majority
and this is it the sky news projection
is that the majority will be between 78
and 82 the highest majority for any
government since 2001 the Tony Blair
years we hope to hear from our election
analyst professor Michael Frazier he's
been involved in that projection pretty
soon but he's well he's getting a seat
put in there he'll be with us very soon
come on Michael
I know it's early in the morning and
you've been up all night rien formal
microphone no formality now this time in
the morning tell us about that I mean
the size of that majority I said it's a
Blair right majority yes and let's just
let's just remind ourselves of what we
said at 10 o'clock with the exit poll we
said a majority of 86 and this
projection after all of these results
takes us pretty near that it's only two
or three seats and for the Conservatives
so I think that's a remarkable yeah
performance by the exit poll how does it
do it how does it get it so accurately
you mean you're in you're involved in it
this is well two back to back and plenty
more before that yeah I mean in truth
what happens is that you make a forecast
on every constituency and then you add
all those probabilities up and you come
up with a number and if you examine the
detailed entrails of all the results the
exit Polo's missed some or is overshot
some and you kind of hope that the error
more or less balanced is an which it has
done can I can I don't watch this how
stressful is it how stress was it having
to do the exit polling and waiting all
night to see if you're right or wrong do
you get really stressed or just to be
honest with you they it is so exciting
waiting for that initial view of what
the exit poll is telling you and it told
us it was quite a sizable conservative
majority but then as more labor voters
command during the day that the size of
the conservative majority you know did
reduce and it reduce all the way through
until we got to that eight we're
expecting a Majoris what you said to me
a few days ago you were exposed to a
majority didn't you I knew I sort of
thought yes there will be a conservative
majority what I didn't and therefore I
was pitching around about 40 or 50 but I
also added that if Labour imploded in
some parts of the country which well it
did you've seen well New England
Scotland and parts of Wales yes and
therefore it was going to increase the
the conservative majority and in in you
know so to get a majority like this and
we are the difference between a majority
of 78 or 82 is three seats yeah so we're
waiting for same times right if the
Tories lose st. Ives obviously their
majority goes down if they lose
Cheltenham to live down you know so
there are a little still many for those
young on there but this is it easily a
working majority vote for Johnson and as
you say it's the largest majority since
Blair in the 2001 general election so
it's a amazing performance really and
it's after for conservative Innes
administration it's of course some of
them have been truncated for the reasons
we all know about but it is is that
unprecedented to put on so many things
well certainly in the modern era to add
votes in the way that you know the
conservative vote share has increased
over these elections but I think it also
reflects upon the poor performance of
labour as well I mean you know the
Conservatives looked good because labour
have performs so poorly and and the
problem was all along that Labour was
having to fight on two fronts it was it
was trying to defend seats in strong
remain areas and it was trying to defend
those seats in strongly varies you just
can't fight on two fronts and they end
up with an ambiguous position on the
most important issue of the day in the
brexit election and and they pay the
price could you say all say that
although Boris Johnson's taken the
spoils big time tonight that Teresa made
did a lot of the groundwork for him in
2017 so a lot of the
seeds it was the same strategy really
wasn't it and a lot of these seats were
swinging in anyway to the Conservatives
but she just missed out a week away and
he gave her the final heat yeah
in one sense yes in another sense you
know what's been happening in these
constituencies is the there's been
demographic changes taking place and and
we focused in in our campaign courage on
what's been happening in many towns and
contrast that with cities so that labor
has performed okay in the cities but
it's not perform very well in the towns
and the conservative just marched into
these areas not to find this ground and
it will take the Labor Party I think
more than one election to recover from
Sybil to bring in John Berger John burka
and then it's that time in the morning
now I know you've observed many many of
the MPS up close and personal
over the years in in the House of
Commons and you know you're quite good
at giving us some flavor of how they
speak how might we imagine Boris Johnson
addressing the the troops after this
tremendous victory he'll get a hero's
welcome
he knows that very large numbers of
those new members have arrived in the
house thanks to him and very importantly
they know that they are arriving in the
House of Commons very much thanks to him
so well there of course it's customary
for conservative leaders and cabinet
ministers as Michael Gove did earlier in
the proceedings to say well we've got
lots of wonderful candidates around the
country and all of that is no doubt true
and each party can say that the truth is
that the leadership matters the framing
of the narrative matters the passion and
energy of the communication matter and
these people who come into the house
Commons the first time will feel an oval
riding sense of gratitude to the Prime
Minister and as good boys and good girls
and appreciative boys of appreciate
those they'll want to support I fall
into line what about some you know the
course of the campaign what about the
the oratory you know how you've heard
Betty a good speeches made a few
yourself you make plenty yourself how is
Boris Johnson
on that scaling I've never myself
regarded Boris Johnson as an orator he
can be very witty he can have a deft
turn of phrase he's got a certain aplomb
and panache I'm not sure that many
people would call him an orator but you
know he has something about him he is
obviously an intriguing and too many
people charismatic character there are
many criticisms that can be lobbed at
him but look tonight this morning he has
clearly won he's won big he deserves the
attention of the country and the
opportunity to put into practice his
philosophy his program and his policies
and Beth how how has he done Eton
educated you know plenty of others in in
that cabinet gone to these areas of the
country where you know they wouldn't
allow a taller dog in me in the past yes
but how does it be done look if you
actually look at the ratings of Boris
Johnson through the campaign he's got
less popular with the public okay so he
started off with pretty good and I I've
got them here I don't know if I can find
them in ties but he got he started off
with quite good favorability ratings
relatively and he actually takes
downwards in the election and actually
Jeremy Corbyn managed to have Boris
Johnson's need so I just want to frame
it in basically it's not because the
country really loved Boris Johnson that
the Tories got this majority as I was
saying in the campaign it almost became
a race of which of these two people is
the least repellent to you to be honest
bricks it deep the the message in and
the message discipline and you've got to
give it to that vote leave team in
number ten the guys that and and the
girls that did the vote leave campaign
in 2016 with take back control they read
a recruit they went into number ten they
were run in a government but really they
were running a campaign machine again
and they came out with get brexit done
and it was so powerful and if I say to
you what was labor and strapline in the
elec
do you know what it was well it was
let's have a renegotiation that'll take
about three months and then we'll have
another referendum and I might or might
not campaign in favor of it do you know
when a party has got a good message we
did a couple of focus crews and people
were parroting backward just think get
brexit done and when people are
unprompted running out your slogans
Labor's this time was time for change
but it didn't cut through in the way
that get brexit done did so it was just
a very very wet again and the Tories
didn't take risks they didn't take risks
I suppose there was the risk of the
election but beyond that as far as some
cravings of resistant a narrative was
concerned they didn't take risks they
closed down the negatives and they
resisted where they felt they could and
you mention any scrutiny as well he did
have impressive message message
discipline in all the press conferences
in you know the interviews yet that it
was he it was that message on loop and
he did do that he did do that well he
did do it yes I remember those
head-to-head debates every answer was
well after we get breaks
we were playing gets wrecks it does
bingo event yes ed Conway's standing by
because we want to examine a very
important feature of this election
campaign do you remember all these all
this talk about all the the new
registrations that had been taking place
that the millions of people that were
apparently registering and it was
thought that too many of them were were
young people and would vote to not get
brexit done that they do they'd form
another youthquake which exactly 2017
did it happen any of it in 29 yeah that
was it and everyone talks about in 2017
and said there is the youth cake quake
and then actually when the British
electoral survey looked at it they found
maybe it wasn't really a youth quake and
it's worth just looking at what we know
so far from the data that we've got here
before we do that though I want to show
you just for me this is perhaps the best
way of looking at the results that we've
had so far because you get a sense of
which where the gains are coming from
for the Conservative Party and where the
losses are coming from from the Labour
Party so have a look at
that's hopped in there you have the
tories 355 seats and let's move across
to the right and you can see 56 gains
for the Tory party you see that up there
let's add on who those gains have come
from and then you can see 53 of those
gains have come for the Labour 43 from
the Lib Dems and then none from the
other parties and then over on the other
side you can see the Tories about 10
losses to a variety of parties and now
look at labour I mean I think it's stark
isn't it one gain net from the Tory
party and just have a look at this over
here 59 losses 59 losses in 53 of them
to the Tory party we've covered a little
bit perhaps some of the demographic
reasons why that might well be brexit
being a large part of it it must be said
but let's look at another question which
is age and youth comparator just just
the proportion of people below the age
of 45 within particular constituencies
and here we have two ends of the
spectrum here Norfolk North one of the
oldest constituencies in the country so
the proportion of people under the age
of 45 29.1 say one of the oldest and
partly that was a conservative game
before you know worth putting out
conservative game from the Liberal
Democrats Norman lamb their former MP
there and then here we have a labour
gained from the conservative that Labour
gained from the Conservatives it's is in
Putney where it's one of the younger
constituencies and if we take all of
these constituencies across the UK
Norfolk North around there and plot them
against how old people are let's move
those over here you can see the
different picture the changing picture
of Britain's political landscape the
older the area is these are the older
areas of the UK they're more blue they
are look the more blue there that's
Norfolk north over there then more blue
they are the younger they are the more
they go for labour you know this is a
real change in the landscape in the UK
happening over the course of this
election Dermot a demographic divided
thank you very much indeed for that well
now the brexit election may nearly be
over well it is over formally the
Conservatives have won but their
reaction to it of course has barely
begun my colleague Aberle has
special edition of Gabe early at
breakfast live from Westminster in a few
minutes time inkay what a night what a
morning
indeed so brilliant work guys during the
night you knocked the spots off the rest
of them both you better than the rest of
the team you've done an absolutely
fantastic job headlines of the night a
massive Tory win and the scalps of the
leaders that they have claimed along the
way Nigel Dodds of course who is the
Westminster leader of the DUP he lost
his seat Joe Swinson the Lib Dem leader
she lost her seat Richard ties the
chairman of the brexit party it didn't
even get a seat in Hartlepool and Jeremy
Corbyn it's a moot point as to whether
or not he has resigned but certainly
he's handed in his notice and he said on
after a period of reflection he will no
longer be leading the Labour Party to
reflect on that talking points weird
will Walden will Walden you'll know he
was the former press man for Boris
Johnson managed to get him elected as
mayor Craig Oliver he'll be here he did
the same for camera and Alastair
Campbell you'll know him and polly
mckenzie he's special advisor formally
to Nick Clegg all of that to come and
I've got a funky set as well here with
the Palace of Westminster just behind me
all of that to come in just a few
moments time but for now back to you
okay now funky said there quite a few
results still to come in as well so stay
with Kay for all that now listen Boris
Johnson we've been talking about the the
triumph or the Prime Minister we've got
some audio we've heard him speaking to
some of their workers at Conservative
Party headquarters a little bit earlier
this morning let's listen in when the
Conservative Party genuinely speaks for
every part of the country
[Applause]
working gentle working have not 100
years which I first contested 22 years
ago with Sandy flat 5 well an ebullient
Boris Johnson there recorded at a
Conservative Party headquarters
congratulating they start from all the
workers on a incredibly successful
campaign got a couple of minutes skies
in this studio before we hand over to
Gabe early to sum it all up oh what do
you take away from an extraordinary
evening
well my first takeaway is there is a
prime minister that took a big gamble he
could have gone down as the worst fire
minister in recent history if he'd and
we're taking this down but and
shortest-lived and lost and he took the
gamble and he won and he won big and now
he has got a five-year term with a
proper majority to change this country
in a way that he sees fit and legislate
he will get for exit done and that is a
incredible achievement for Boris Johnson
and his team okay John Burke oh and
thank you very much indeed for being
with us to take me those constituencies
during the course of this dramatic
evening what are you making what what do
you take away from it all
it's an unalloyed triumph for Boris
Johnson it is a total disaster for the
Labor Party and it's an utter misery for
the Liberal Democrats as a party and for
Joseph Winston personally Boris
Johnson's got a terrific opportunity
he's got the power he's got the numbers
he's got the bandwidth both to deliver
his policy on brexit although there are
other actors on the stage and the second
and subsequent phases
of that policy will take time and they
will be subject to the views of others
in Europe and Beyond but he does have
that opportunity and he's got an
opportunity to frame a policy for the
country as a whole at rank John thank
you very much indeed and that's it for
me at least on the brexit election much
more to come an election won
convincingly by Boris Johnson and the
Conservatives Cape early will be taking
over the battle at Westminster as
Britain wakes up to the result but from
me and the team here in the sky LexA
Center it's goodbye John Bercow bring us
to order order order goodbye the exit
poll is predicting is indicating it's a
conservative win that the Conservatives
will have 368 seats
chin yellow Susan inverter 20 1560
the Conservative Party candidates 32000
[Applause]
I want to also make it clear that I will
not lead the party in any future general
election campaign have you lost your
seat mr. Winston and I declare that Amy
Callaghan has elected to serve in the
United Kingdom Parliament as the member
for the Eastern Partnership and tone
taken statutes
[Applause]
I hereby declare that the said Boris
Johnson is duly elected at this stage it
does look as though this one nation
Conservative government has been given a
powerful new mandate well that's it
confirmation of the result the
Conservatives have formally won this
general election
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you